welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr Shawn
Mackey Dr Shawn Mackey is a medical
doctor that is he treats patients as
well as a PhD meaning he runs a
laboratory he is the chief of the
division of pain medicine and a
professor of both anesthesiology and
neurology at Stanford University School
of Medicine today we discuss what is
pain most of us are familiar with the
notion of pain from having a physical
injury or some sort of chronic pain or a
headache today Dr Macky makes clear what
the origins of pain are both in the
nervous system and outside the nervous
system that is the interactions between
the brain and the body that give rise to
this thing that we call pain indeed we
discussed the critical link between
physical pain and emotional pain and how
altering one's perception of emotional
or physical pain can often change the
other we also discuss some of the
changes in the nervous system that occur
when we experience pain and how that can
give rise to chronic pain we also of
course cover different methods to reduce
pain safely and those methods include
behavioral tools psychological tools
nutrition supplementation and of course
prescription drugs we discussed the
intimate relationship between
temperature that is heat and cold and
pain and Pain Relief so if you're
interested in the use of heat or cold to
modulate pain that conversation ought to
be of interest as well we also touch on
some highly controversial topics such as
opioids opioids are a substance that
your body naturally makes but of course
many people are familiar with exogenous
opioids that is opioids that are
available as drugs and the so-called
opioid crisis Dr Mai makes very clear
which specific clinical circumstances
weren't the use of exogenous opioids
with of of course a warning about their
potent addictive potential and we get
into a bit of discussion about where the
opioid crisis and the use of opioid
drugs to control pain is and is going
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is Aeropress
Aero press is similar to a French press
for making coffee but is in fact a much
better way to make coffee the Aero press
was developed by Allan Adler who's an
engineer at Stamford I knew of Allen
because I used to see him in my hometown
of paloalto test flying the so-called
aobi frisbee so he was sort of famous
around my town as This brilliant
engineer that would create these unusual
products so when I heard about the Aro
press I got it I tried it and I
absolutely loved it because it does
indeed create the best taste in cup of
coffee or loose leaf tea with Aero press
you can brew an incredible tasting
coffee or tea and clean up the whole
process in less than 2 minutes the key
thing to know about the Arrow Press is
that it's not just some trivial
variation on the French press that
shortened Brewing time that the arero
Press uses really changes the flavor of
your cup of coffee or tea it makes it
exceptionally smooth if you'd like to
try arero press you can go to Aero
press.com huberman that's a r o p r
ss.com /h huberman to get 20% off any
Aeropress coffee maker Aeropress ships
anywhere in the USA Canada and over 60
other countries around the world again
that's Aeropress
dcom to get 20% off today's episode is
also brought To Us by levels levels is a
program that lets you see how different
foods and activities impacts your blood
glucose levels using a continuous
glucose monitor one of the most
important factors impacting your energy
levels as well as your immediate and
long-term Health are your blood blood
glucose levels sometimes referred to as
your blood sugar levels to maintain
mental and physical energy and focus you
want your blood glucose levels to be
relatively stable throughout the day
levels makes it extremely easy to
determine how specific foods and food
combinations meal timing exercise and
sleep work alone and in combination to
impact your blood glucose levels I
started using levels about two years ago
and find it to be immensely beneficial
it's helping me better arrange what I
eat when I eat when to exercise
and my sleep pattern so if you're
interested in learning more about levels
and trying a CGM yourself go to levels.
l/ huberman levels has launched a new
CGM sensor that is smaller and has even
better tracking than the previous
versions right now they are also
offering an additional two free months
of membership again that's levels. linkl
nk/ huberman today's episode is also
brought To Us by betterhelp betterhelp
offers Professional Therapy with a
licensed therapist carried out online
now I've been going to therapy for well
over 30 years initially I didn't have a
choice it was a condition of being
allowed to stay in school but pretty
soon I realize that therapy is extremely
valuable in fact I consider doing
regular therapy just as important as
getting regular exercise including
cardiovascular exercise and resistance
training which of course I also do every
week the reason I know therapy is so
valuable is that if you can find a
therapist with whom you can develop a
really good rapport you not only get
terrific support for some of the
challenges in your life but you also can
derive tremendous insights from that
therapy insights that can allow you to
better not just your emotional life and
your relationship life but of of course
also the relationship to yourself and to
your professional life to all sorts of
career goals in fact IC therapy is one
of the key components for meshing
together all aspects of one's life and
being able to really direct one's focus
and attention toward what really matters
with better help they make it extremely
easy to find a therapist that's ideal
for your needs your life circumstances
and that can match to your schedule in a
very convenient way if you'd like to try
betterhelp go to betterhelp.com huberman
to get 10% off your first month again
that's betterhelp.com
huberman and now for my discussion with
Dr Shawn Mackey Dr Mackey welcome oh
it's a pleasure to be here thank you
this is a long time coming we're
colleagues at Stanford and I'm familiar
with your work but today we're going to
take a pretty Broad and deep survey of
this thing called pain so I'll just
start off very simply and ask what is
pain pain is this complex and subjective
experience that serves a crucial role
for all of us to keep us away from
injury or
harm it is both a sensory and an
emotional experience and I think that
gets lost on people that includes this
emotional component to it and it is
incredibly individual and we'll get more
into that hopefully as time goes by that
you know your pain is different from my
pain and is different from everybody
else's it takes an incredible toll on
society when it goes chronic when it
becomes persistent to the tune of about
a 100 million Americans and at last
count about a half a trillion dollars a
year in medical expenses uh so an
astounding problem we're facing in
society and one that's only getting
worse and I'm hoping during the course
of this discussion that we can kind of
break down a little bit of the
foundation of pain and kind of build it
back up because
unfortunately uh in society there's a
lot of misunderstanding about what pain
is and I think uh hopefully we can build
that foundation and then layer on some
some useful treatments and useful
options for people I'm glad you pointed
out this link between the sensory and
the emotional experience every once in a
while I'll pull something or I'll have
like you know like a kink in my neck or
my back and fortunately for me it
resolves pretty quickly but I notice
that when I'm experiencing that kind of
pain that I become slightly more
irritable perhaps much more irritable
depending on who you ask and that
everything becomes more challenging
thinking is harder sleeping is harder
concentrating on anything besides pain
it's it's a um it's as if something's
nagging from the inside and so that
raises the the next question that I have
which is
is pain something that's in our brain in
our body or both it's clearly in our
brain and can I take a moment to kind of
lay a little foundation for some of that
to help clear up some of the mystery of
pain we know that pain most pain all
starts with some stimulus whether it be
that kink in your neck or your shoulder
from working out or turning the wrong
way and what's going on there uh in your
body is not pain what's going on is that
uh there are sensors in our skin our
soft tissue our deep tissues called
noors and these noors are sensing
elements and they sense different types
of stimuli they can sense temperature uh
heat cold they sense pressure they can
sense pH changes due to for instance
inflammation that may occur from uh any
something going on in your neck or your
shoulder those signals up nerve fiber
types and the two that we we refer to
are a Delta and C fibers one transmits
very fast it's responsible that you know
sharp jolt of pain that goes to your
brain when we uh you know step on a tack
or put our hand on a hot stove and
there's another fiber called a CA fiber
which is much slower and responsible for
that dull achy pain now these signals
they go to the spinal cord lie up and
down our uh from our head down to our
back and they're they're shaped they're
changed a little
bit they then are sent up to the brain
and it's once they hit the brain and
they converge with this Magical Mystery
set of nerves in the brain that it
becomes the experience of pain and if
there's one key message I'd like to get
to the audience is that what goes on out
here what goes on in your shoulder in
your neck is not pain that's no
susception those are
electrical signals electrochemical
impulses being transmitted and that is
to be distinguished from what becomes
the subjective experience of pain that
you have and why it's
critical is that our brain serves so
many functions of emotions cognitions uh
memory action all of that shapes those
signals coming in from our body to
create your unique experience of pain
that's different from everybody
else's and I think that's important to
note
because we are frequently left with this
notion of this
onetoone concordance between the
stimulus and the experience of pain you
know Renee Dart that French uh
philosopher I think 17th
century um was the one who first
postulated this idea of this direct
linkage between the body and our actions
and the stimulus and the response and
it's wrong and unfortunately even in
medical care we have this biomedical
model that still is perpetuating this
idea of a onetoone
relationship and that's a critically
important point to get
across in large part because frequently
as humans we tend to project onto others
our own experiences of pain and when we
see somebody who's got an injury or
something else going on we immediately
put that on them and that has also been
a problem uh with many people suffering
in chronic pain which is often viewed as
the invisible disease so when you say we
put that on them you mean when somebody
reports being in pain we have a hard
time understanding what they're are
experiencing because it's going to be
very different than the way that we
experience pain conversely if somebody's
in pain they tend to assume that people
are experiencing pain the way that they
are do I have that right you have it
perfectly right and it actually if I can
build on that gets worse because
sometimes you have conditions like
fibromyalgia that maybe we'll get into
where outwardly visibly you don't see
anything wrong we're used to thinking of
pain as a fractured you know bone as a
swollen ankle we see that and then we
like okay well you've got pain you got
legitimate pain whereas this invisible
disease of chronic pain frequently you
don't have something outwardly that
you're seeing but we bring in our own
history of pain and we put that on other
people I have a question that's somewhat
mechanistic but we'll keep it accessible
to anybody regardless of their
background so you mentioned the NOS
acceptors are in the body and everywhere
in the body and on the surface of the
body to be able to detect certain kinds
of stimula and then those signals are
sent up into the brain and the Brain
creates this subjective experience that
we call pain is there a dedicated set of
areas in the brain that that are
something akin to like a pain pathway
and the reason I ask this is that for
you know for vision for hearing for
touch we probably all experience those
somewhat differently your perception of
red is probably a little different than
my perception of red we don't know for
sure but experiments support that idea
but there's a major difference between
people experiencing the same thing
differently according to like a
mysterious mechanism in the brain as
opposed to like a an area in the brain
that we can look and say like hey like
like that's where pain is uh represented
that's where all these these inputs from
the body are put together to create this
thing that we call pain um like is there
an area of the the thalamus a structure
in the middle of the brain that takes
incoming sensory information that we
could say oh that's the pain pathway is
there a part of our neocortex the outer
shell of the the brain more or less um
beneath the skull but nonetheless on the
outer portion of the human brain that we
could say oh that's where pain exists or
is it a distributed phenomenon yeah
that's a great question and you know
because we'd all love if there was a
pain center in the brain that we could
just go knock out but it's not that
simple and in part because pain is such
a conserved phenomenon it it is there it
is so wonderful because it is so
terrible unless it goes wrong
but when you knock out one pathway going
to the brain there's others there that
will carry that system forward and
you'll still experience pain and it's
there to keep us all alive now to get to
your point no there's not one pain brain
area it is thought to be more of a
distributed network of different brain
systems we at one point in time called
it the pain Matrix which represented
areas such as uh the insular cortex the
singulate
cortex the amydala a number of these
brain regions that all subserve
different functions we moving away from
that because it seems like every year or
so we pick up another region of the
brain that's contributing to this
network that subserves some additional
function some nuanced layer to
it that
said we have been able to identify some
common signatures common brain networks
that seem to represent the experience of
pain and this is where the development
of brain-based biomarkers has come in
and this is some of the work that I've
done
starting gosh well over a dozen years
ago and uh others have been building on
and what we're finding is that there
does seem to be this this conserved
region set of uh distributed regions
that do represent the experience of pain
so when somebody takes a so-called
painkiller let let's take a uh typical
over-the-counter painkiller like a
ibuprofen or camenen to uh lessen pain
of some kind yeah where is that drug or
drugs acting is it in the body or is it
at the level of the brain or both yeah
and this is where some of the challenges
we get into with language because
technically nids nonsteroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs like ibuprofen
like
Naperson they're actually not analgesics
they're not technically pain killers so
an analgesic is the descriptor for a
quote unquote painkiller yeah there that
would be more correct like an opioid
would be would fit into that category
the N heads are anti-inflammatory drugs
they're also there's another this is a
technical term they're
anti-hyperalgesic drugs and
so one of the things that happens after
an injury is that we get
sensitization of the area that's injured
and it's a beautiful thing because it
sends a message to us to protect it um
what the end heads do is they reduce
some of that sensitization out in the
periphery and then back in the spinal
cord and in the brain but they don't
actually so for instance I was going to
say try this at home but probably not
you can um in a normal situation you
know hit your hand with a fork measure
the amount of pain I'll go take an NSAID
like ibuprofen if you hit your hand with
that same Fork there'll be no difference
folks please don't do that don't do that
at home please yeah or any or anywhere
for that matter or anywhere for that
matter but you're describing pain and
the local inflammation response and the
hyper Alesia the increase in pain in
that general area as something very
adaptive very important so it raises the
question what is the threshold for
saying that somebody should treat their
pain reduce their pain I mean you know
anytime I've done um you know surgeries
on animals which I don't do anymore in
the laboratory but we used to you know
you would give them painkillers
post-operatively I've had iies before I
had painkillers postoperatively although
I don't like taking them I don't like
the way they make my brain feel and so
uh but we of course know that if you
increase the dose of any pain medication
too much then that animal or a human can
potentially injure themselves worse or
not protect that injured area so it
raises a whole set of sort of medical
ethical but also just purely biological
questions how do you set the threshold
for yes blunt pain versus no allow the
pain to be there as an adaptive way of
protecting yourself in healing
presumably the inflammation is part of
the healing process too and as you
mentioned before pain is so subjective
and it's different between all of us I
mean how do we decide uh whether or not
it's a good or bad idea to blunt that
pain yeah I think the the the threshold
is when it's impacting your quality of
life and your ability to take care of
activities at daily living engage with
family friends go to work
and that that s kind of a your your
threshold for you know whether it's
reasonable to to take a medication or
not it's a lot of controversy in the
space right now it used to be we all
recommended just Neds for any type of
acute injury I is non-steroid
anti-inflammatory drugs indeed could
could we maybe list off a few of those
so I mentioned ibuprofen aceto Menin so
sometimes referred to as you know the
classic Advil Tylenol we won't throw out
name brands there but what are some
others Naproxin neoen is another one
Toral or ketorolac is another one the
two over-the-counter nids the
prototypical over-the-counter ones are
ibuprofen and napasin those are the ones
you can buy over the counter without a
prescription uh Tylenol actually has a
slightly different mechanism of injury
but you know still fits in that same
general class it tends to be more
centrally acting IBU uh Tylenol or
camenen but take we say centrally you
mean Brain Brain Brain thank you than
you and uh is aspirin considered an
insat I don't believe as would fit into
that category of basically a Cox cyc
oxygenase inhibitor this is one of the
the chemical mediators that gets
released during injury and that chemical
uh substance has a tendency to wind up
or amplify the
noors so that after an injury you note
that you're more sensitive there after a
sunburn you end up having more
sensitization that is what we refer to
as peripheral sensitization because it's
out in the periphery we're winding up or
amplifying the
response uh aspirin n heads in general
will reduce that inflammation they're
anti- um
hyperalgesic and uh pardon again the
jargony terms that we use but hope
coming across along as we go but but you
know to your point you don't want to for
instance let's imagine you have a
fractured ankle
you don't want to be reaching for a very
potent
opioid just so that you can continue
walking on a fractured ankle that you
haven't gotten evaluated by a clinician
and perhaps casted that wouldn't be safe
those are rather extreme examples you
know we get into those debates right in
professional sports where you know they
they send the person back out on the
field with a broken bone you know having
given them an ejection or something I'm
I'm hoping that doesn't go on anymore
but uh I'm sure it goes on okay yeah
well there's all sorts of other things I
get contacted all the time professional
teams and athletes asking how they can
get back in quicker nowadays the big
thing are these uh peptides that can
certainly accelerate healing people are
traveling out of country get stem cell
injections all with all with uh very few
randomized control trials but I assure
you that um Courtside and in the locker
room mainly in the locker room their
corticosteroid injections their
painkiller injections I mean it's it's
not at any expense but it's not far from
that okay yeah yeah well you know when
you're you're making millions of dollars
a year and I I get the being back on the
field but for the rest of us mere
mortals um I think that's where we would
want to draw a line get medical
attention if you've got an acute injury
going a little bit deeper into mechanism
because I think it's going to serve us
well now and going forward you mentioned
the IDS and um this uh Cox Cox is one of
it's a is it in the family of PR gland
can we talk about prandin because I
think there are a lot of people nowadays
we hear about inflammation yeah you know
inflammation's bad inflammation's bad
but you know one of the things that we
talk about a lot on this podcast is the
fact that you know cortisol isn't bad
inflammation isn't bad these things
serve an important biological role so
the prostaglandins seem to be one of the
main ways that our immune system uh
responds to a physical or chemical
injury and and creates inflammation and
that as you said that inflammation
sensitizes an area makes it literally
more sensitive and then we introduce
these drugs that um to restore normal
functioning and living could we
establish like what normal functioning
is I mean for instance if we make this
really concrete could we say well if you
can sleep fall asleep at night and stay
asleep or perhaps go back to sleep after
you've woken up in the middle of the
night then will you heal during sleep
and so you know take as little
painkiller as possible but enough that
still still lets you sleep well at night
is that it's sort of normal functioning
because when I have a kink in my neck I
don't want to do much of anything I try
but it's really frustrating so what is I
mean as a physician how and as a patient
how do we determine normal functioning
yeah and you're getting into the Nuance
the complexity of this problem because
we've been talking about NSAIDs the IB
prence and
napins and as I said early on we used to
just give these out all the time but
then the research comes out and shows
that by blocking inflammation by
blocking that we may be blocking the
normal healing process and so we've seen
delays in fracture repair we've been
seeing delays in tissue repair and so
now you've got on one hand a medication
that may help with pain help you improve
function you've got on the other hand
something you're taking that may delay
the process where do you draw the line
as a physician my Approach is really
basically what you said it's balancing
the fact that if you're not sleeping at
night you're not going to heal and
you're not going to be able to do what
you need to do the next day and if
taking an inset helps you sleep and
helps you uh engage with what you need
to do take it at the lowest dose that
you can get away
with I've heard before that NAD should
be taken no more than once every six
hours people will alternate different
types of ins
that's usually try reduce fever another
situation where an Adaptive response
fever you know people go out of their
way to block it right prevent the brain
from cooking but again opens up the same
set of issues and so I'm wondering if
somebody has some pain that makes you
know moving about frustrating and it's
and it's difficult but you know they can
sleep at night reasonably well maybe not
as well as they normally do would your
suggestion to that person if their goal
is to heal as quickly as possible to
just not take anything yeah so we've got
a lot more data on the benefits of nids
this class of medication reducing pain
then we have data uh showing the bad
consequences of it and so we're still
needing more data on the whole healing
message I think that a lot of the
orthopedic surgeons out there prefer
people not to be on IDs after for
instance a total hip replacement at
total knee replacement because I think
that's pretty clear but that's not what
we're talking about right now so so one
of the other interesting things about n
heads like we mentioned ibuprofin and
aprin huge individual variability around
those so personally ibuprofen is not
very effective for me napasin is for
others it may be just exactly the
opposite so there's value in rotating
them and finding out which works best
for your particular situation you
mentioned the timing of it ibuprofen is
typically given no more than three times
a a day it's got a short halflife
Naperson twice a day what's critical I
need to give this message is in both
situations make sure that you have food
in your stomach make sure you're not
taking it on an empty stomach make sure
you're drinking plenty of fluids and if
you've got any um GI issues if you've
got any bleeding issues if you've got
kidney issues if you've got heart issues
talk to your doc talk to your clinician
before you embark on this because these
medications do have side effects and
adverse consequences in vulnerable
people and what about aspirin I've heard
that aspirin can benefit heart health so
I take a baby aspirin every day and if I
have a pain that is just too intense for
normal functioning as we're defining it
then I'll increase that um dose of
aspirin and I just assume aspirin is the
healthiest and sad for me because well
it's also good for heart health and it's
killing pain in those instances as
opposed to taking anything else is my
logic flawed and if it is feel free to
tell me no for for you your logic is
perfect and that's where it gets to the
individual person and for a lot of
people that model would work as well so
baby asper in 81 milligrams a day acts
as an antiplatelet agent it helps you
know here even though we're getting
controversy over the role of baby
aspirin if you dive into the current
literature even baby aspirin is
controversial even baby aspirin these
days and now what they're doing with
with the data is defining age ranges
when they say baby aspirin yes baby
aspirin no and so you know we're
learning a lot more about that I still
take a baby aspirin every day yeah I
take a baby aspirin you get to the
higher dose is say four times as much up
around 325 milligrams or so it's now an
anti-inflammatory it's now acting more
like the ibuprofen and the
napasin so um different mechanisms of
action at different
doses I'd like to take a brief moment
and thank one of our sponsors and that's
ag1 ag1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that also contains adaptogens I
started taking ag1 way back in 2012 the
reason I started taking it and the
reason I still take it every day is that
it ensures that I meet all of my quotas
for vitamins and minerals and it ensures
that I get enough preotic and probiotic
to support gut health now gut health is
something that over the last 10 years we
realized is not just important for the
health of our gut but also for our
immune system and for the production of
neurotransmitters and neuromodulators
things like dopamine and serotonin in
other words gut health is critical for
proper brain functioning now of course I
strive to consume healthy Whole Foods
for the majority of my nutritional
intake every single day but there are a
number of things in ag1 including
specific micronutrients that are hard to
get from Whole Foods or at least in
sufficient quantities so ag1 allows me
to get the vitamins and minerals that I
need probiotics prebiotics the
adaptogens and critical micronutrients
so anytime somebody asks me if they were
to take Just One supplement what that
supplement should be I tell them ag1
because ag1 supports so many different
systems within the body that are
involved in mental health physical
health and performance to try ag1 go to
drink a1.com huberman and you'll get a
year supply of vitamin D3 K2 and five
free travel packs of ag1 again that's
drink a1.com
huberman I promise we won't go into
every medication in such detail but but
these are the most commonly used
over-the-counter treatments for pain as
far as I know know um are there any um
issues with you know people who drink
caffeine who then are taking these drugs
are like what are some of the uh the uh
interactions that these things can have
as far as I know caffeine actually
touches into the prostag gland in
pathway doesn't it yes and that's where
you know caffeine can be used
effectively for headaches for migraines
and uh it can help potentiate the
analgesic response uh some people get uh
stomach irritation though with caffeine
so just again mind that you take an nsid
with uh a lot of coffee uh have some
food in your stomach you know you
brought up earlier aeta menen or Tylenol
Tylenol doesn't have the same side
effect or adverse event profile that the
Nets do so Tylenol is safe on the
stomach um where you need to be careful
about Tylenol is not to exceed 4,000
milligrams or four grams per day in
divided
doses so two extra strength Tylenol done
four times a day for many people is safe
some say two grams some say four grams
the key here is around your liver so if
you've got good liver function if you're
not abusing alcohol that's a general
rule of thumb that you can use for
Tylenol um but it's not going to upset
your stomach there are versions of the
NSAIDs that we refer to as Cox 2
inhibitor they're very selective like
celic coxib that is uh less irritating
on the stomach that's by prescription
only though but you can think of it as
working very much the same as the
napasin and the ibuprofen so talk with
your clinician you know to to try to
tease those apart if you have problems
in your stomach with the NSAIDs and
they're really effective for you you can
be given other types of medications that
help block or reduce the GI issues
associated with the
insets very useful information thank you
here we're talking about chemical
interventions to the pain
process what about mechanical
interventions so I was taught in my
basic Neuroscience about I think it's
melzack and walls gate theory of pain do
I have this right where you know we all
have this instinctual response animals
have it too right if they uh you bump
your knee or your toe that you grab and
you rub it and that that rubbing
response is actually contributing to the
activation of a neural pathway that does
indeed reduce the pain through a
legitimate neural inhibition and tell me
if this is still considered correct and
then I'll let you um uh elaborate on it
but I think that is an opportunity for
us to also talk more generally or for
you to educate us more generally on the
the mechanistic interventions for pain
like um maybe massage above or below the
sight of pain maybe acupuncture um so
again there will be chemical
consequences of any mechanical
intervention right as we know because
that's the language of the nervous
system electricity and chemicals but as
opposed to taking a drug you can imagine
using manual um stimulation or rubbing
around it or or perhaps we can also talk
about heat and cold so can we explore
that space a bit absolutely and first
you're right so uh in your first part uh
pack uh Patrick Wall Ron mzac luminaries
in the field of pain back in the 60s uh
defined the gate control theory of pain
and one of the things to build on the
story that we talked about with no
receptors going to the spinal signals
going to the spinal cord heading up to
the brain where the perception of pain
occurs that's not where the story ends
it turns out there are Pathways that
come down from the brain down from the
brain to the spinal cord that act in an
inhibitory role and we'll build on those
also from the
periphery we've got also fibers called
touch fibers these are the ones where
they get activated with light touch
stroking they refer to as a beta fibers
they're fast
conducting they head back to the spinal
cord and they make some
connections with those notive
fibers so with that grounding imagine
what you said your you hit your thumb
with a hammer you um uh you bang
something on an extremity uh what is the
first thing you do when you hit your
thumb with a hammer uh some people rub
it I yell some people swear and it turns
out there are studies that show that
swearing works really swearing reduces
pain better than uh than using
non-explicit
can go out and swear every time they're
in pain well they can but they'll have
to bear the consequences on an
individual basis we're not we're we're
absolving ourselves of any
responsibility right so uh rubbing uh
shaking is another one which basically
is activating those touch fibers oh it
is I do that everybody does that
everybody does that running it underwat
which you know it doesn't matter whether
you know in this case it's hot or it's
cold water it's the running of the water
underneath it and what ises it doing we
all think it's reducing the stimulus out
here and it is not at in the periphery
in the periphery what's magical about
that I think which is so cool is you're
actually changing the signals in your
spinal cord way back here in the neck
this is the cheapest free version of
what we refer to as
neuromodulation that's ever been
discovered um you're actually by doing
that you're changing things the
connections back in your spinal cord and
it's
reducing the no susceptive signals
coming in here that's why we do it and
it works it works beautifully that's why
when a kid gets their boo boo you know
parents come and rub it it works what
about the kiss the kids sometimes they
want to kiss you know or a romantic
partner will sometimes like injure
themselves I guess it depends on the
nature of the relationship and they'll
say like can you kiss it of course you
know then you kiss it and then like they
feel better is that purely
psychological well okay I think an
important point to to to ground here
when it comes to the experience of pain
is that everything when we say
psychological means Neuroscience I know
you know that no no forgive me I I I I
have to be careful with with the the
wording that I use that's my fault but
but it's it's accurate still it is
psychological but it is neuroscience
based I mean they're really becoming one
and the same but to answer your question
yes by kissing it you're activating
touch fibers we can also agree that
there's a positive emotional salience
that's associated with that and that
positive emotional salience is reducing
pain
too what interesting up wall and melac
sometime later uh there was the
introduction of a device to take
advantage of this called the tens device
and tens is an acronym transcutaneous
electrical neuros
stimulation and what the tenens device
is doing and there's many versions of it
now but there are those black electrod
you put over the area and they're hooked
up to wires and when you turn it on it
causes a buzzing
sensation and that buzzing sensation is
activating those touch fibers the a beta
fibers and so it's causing that
neuromodulation back in the spinal cord
amazing it's cool stuff it's very cool
and I and I love that you emphasize that
when we're rubbing the periphery or
shaking our hand the periphery again
being the body surface away from the
brain that the real mechanism of action
is taking place back in the spinal cord
because it really speaks to the the
body-wide and the the circuit wide the
nervous systemwide nature of this thing
that we call pain right it's it's
happening out quote unquote out here in
the periphery but it's being modulated
in the neck level of the spinal cord
approximately and then it's you know
being interpreted at the level of the
brain what
explains different pain thresholds I
could imagine it could be any or all of
the locations that we've been discussing
and it could be the context as well
right if you're um you know I've heard
before and I don't know if this is true
that if you have a lot of adrenaline
epinephrine in your system that your
threshold for pain goes way way
up there's probably a chemical basis for
that and maybe it's all you know um
anecdote but um certainly people have
different thresholds for pain I for
instance do not have a high pain
threshold but I've noticed I have a very
quick pain response so if I stub my toe
it feels like the most painful thing I
could possibly experience but then it's
gone very quickly so it's like a quick
inflection and then down other people I
know uh we've never done the experiment
I think I see them stub their toe and
they're like ah and then you know 10
minutes later they're still feeling the
ache so whose pain threshold is higher
it's a it depends on how you define pain
threshold so so how do we Define pain
threshold what determines pain threshold
and I guess the $6 million question are
there different pain thresholds between
men and women as it relates to the whole
story about childbirth being very
painful and that Women quote unquote
have higher pain thresholds I just I
just sent you about 10 questions forgive
me yeah um so what is pain threshold
yeah no it's a it's a great place to
start and
maybe I don't know if you want to Circle
back around at some point to the heat
and cold to finish up the mechanical but
for no no no you're let me answer your
get to your pain threshold so the pain
threshold is uh that stimulus intensity
that results in the onset of the
experience of pain the first onset of
the experience of pain so you know when
you turn up the heat it's it's not when
it's warm it's not when it's just hot
it's when the the heat
becomes the perception of pain like when
it becomes painfully hot at that point
in time the same works for cold you
mentioned some of the distinction
between your experiences of pain to a
stimulus and your buddies and that's
normal that first onset of pain again
those are those fast fibers those ad
Delta fibers boom right to your brain
those are the protective ones that when
we put our hand on a hot stove we
immediately Jerk it back we don't even
have a conscious perception yet that we
did that and then it's a moment later
when the sea fibers are getting up to
the brain and the other AD Delta fibers
are converging into conscious areas of
brain that we're like oh wow that stove
is really
hot and the ca fibers in particular are
converging on more emotional regions in
the brain that are conveying an
unpleasantness to that experience you
don't like it you and you don't want it
to happen again which is why it encodes
memories so you only had to do that once
as a
child now getting into the the pain
thresholds you asked one of the other
questions is do men and women have
different pain um thresholds uh the
answer the short answer is yes this has
been established
and I want to be careful here with
saying a couple things one is in general
uh men have uh higher paining thresholds
to things like heat stimulus than
women and what what people have to also
though
understand as scientists we make a big
deal out of small differences right you
know what we do is we take a group of
people in this case men and
women and we apply the same uh thermal
stimulus to them and we draw
averages the average man has this
stimulus the average woman has this
stimulus and we say well women have have
a little bit more sensitivity to that
heat stimulus and so we then go into the
press and we say uh men are tougher than
women that's a terrible statement right
because the tough part is a subjective
label right I mean it it it gets to a
whole bunch of different issues around
the Adaptive role of pain right I mean I
mean one could argue that if your
threshold for pain is lower that your it
serves a more adaptive function right
fewer injures Etc I mean I guess it gets
into the implications of what we mean by
quote unquote tougher it does but it
also misses I think the big point which
is people are not
averages so what I mean by that is um
while the average for a woman may be
somewhat less than a man if you look at
the distribution of the curves they
highly
overlap meaning the individual
variability within men and within women
is much greater than the difference
between men and women but there's plenty
of women on that curve that have much
greater heat uh thresholds than men Doh
but when you pull things you end up with
that difference unfortunately when
things are picked up and you want a
quick sound bite out of it that's what
it gets distilled down to so so it's not
unlike height for that matter I me there
a lot of women that are taller than men
that's exactly it but on average men are
taller than women on average and I would
say within this area of uh pain
threshold differences it's even closer
it's even
tighter you know it would be I'm making
this up the equivalent I think the
average height of a woman is 53 5'4 the
average height of a man 5'9 510 this is
Imagining the average height being you
know 5'6 for a woman and 5'8 for a man
you know it's not a huge
difference there's a lot of things that
play into to changes in pain
thresholds how much and this is where
the brain comes in because you know much
of the no subception much of the signals
that we're um transducing were
transmitting you know in many of us it's
very much the same it's when it gets to
the brain now it's shaped and it's
shaped by things such
as um your beliefs about that stimulus
your expectations around it how much
anxiety you're having at the moment does
increased anxiety increase one's
perceived pain yes okay yeah it does um
your early life experiences with this so
have you had traumatic experiences in
the past that alters brain circuits can
I interject a question yeah if one was
told just suck it up a lot or if one
whimpered or cursed when they uh hurt
themselves if they were told um you know
don't be a wuss don't be a
wimp do we know whether or not that
increases or decreases the subjective
feeling of pain later I could imagine it
going either way I could imagine the kid
that was told don't be a wuss when they
cried as a consequence of expressing
pain or an experience of pain secretly
feeling more pain because they aren't
able to express the emotionality around
the pain but that if we just look from
the outside we say wow like pretty tough
adult right because they're not um
crying out in pain so do we have any are
there any experiments that have explored
that I don't know you're getting into
this is a good point getting into um uh
pediatric pain and you know if there's
been experiments in that space I stay
mainly in the adult area and my
experience with raising a child is an N
of one with one son um he's done great
thank you I happen to know him very well
he's a he's he's what you call a great
example of Highly Successful
reproduction so you know it's say what
do they say it's better to be lucky than
good uh so sure I'm sure there was a lot
involved so don't don't discount don't
uh don't discard any credit thank you
thank you um you know my Approach with
Ian was not to say just you know
necessarily suck it up but I would uh
you know make light of it i' I'd have
fun with it and uh I would kind of laugh
and I'm like way to go buddy uh and I
would find he would often laugh you know
so I think a lot of it is the cues
they're taking off the parents you know
and again this is this is just my oneof
end parent is if they see you freaking
out kid's going to freak out too um but
does there get to be a point where
you're ignoring your child or your loved
On's painful issue yeah now you're
getting into some maladaptive some bad
space where I think it's sending that
person the wrong message and they may
very well have problems later
on I will tell just a very brief
anecdote when I was growing up I
observed a total of zero
children and friends who you know cried
out in pain or complained of pain who
were told you know um that was an
inappropriate response um sometimes I
might have heard parents say you know
come on just suck it up or like or rub
it you'll be okay that kind of thing but
once and only once with had some friends
I won't tell you what country they were
from but they they lived not far from um
where both Ian and I grew up since we
grew up near one another and I'll never
forget that the younger brother of a
friend of mine ran over to the father he
had cut his thumb on the band saw and it
wasn't particularly deep but he was
crying in pain and the father wrapped it
picked up his chin and smacked him
across the face and said don't ever do
that again and so what I think he was
doing was compounding the the lesson
about the saw yeah but clearly had no
regard for the pain that the that the
injury probably caused now I haven't
followed up with that kid um I think we
can all agree that by today's standards
that would be considered um abusive
parenting uh or perhaps um you know one
could say that was you know on the far
extreme of a response but I'll never
forget that and I went home and I I told
my mom yeah and she said oh yeah when I
was growing up that was actually a more
frequent response to kids hurting them
themselves especially boys and so things
have really changed in terms of how we
react to children in pain but the reason
I find this interesting is that
ultimately what we're talking about is
how should we interpret our own pain
yeah can I can I make a commentary about
that scenario and I want to bring in
another Neuroscience concept that that
Dad may have been doing
inadvertently and that's something
called conditioned pain
modulation so there's another cool
phenomenon in in pain that pain inhibits
pain so what I mean by that is when you
were you know this guy this kid but or
yourself growing up did you ever walk up
to your buddy and say you know my my arm
really hurts you know I injured it the
other day and what did what did your
buddy do they'd stomp on your foot and
you'd say why the heck did you do that
you I must have growing up with the same
friends oh yeah yeah and and they'd say
well now doesn't doesn't your arm feel
better and i' be like well yeah it does
and yeah I did grow up with those
friends I tell this story to some people
and I sometimes just get the wide eyes
like they did what yeah we are not
making recommendations here we're not
making recommendations but it's a real
phenomenon it was described by
Laars late 70s 78 or something like that
in rodent models initially and what
happens is that when you engage a no
susceptive stimulus or a painful
stimulus and a site distal different
from where the primary pain is it
engages a brain stem circuit that has
descending Pathways to the spinal cord
and inhibits pain amazing pain inhibits
pain it works it also is thought to have
some contributions from higher brain
centers we call this whole phenomenon
lears called this phenomenon diffuse
noxious inhibitory control or denck the
human version of this is called
conditioned pain modulation why I bring
this up not only to help explain that
father's actions
somehow I don't think that he was
thinking oh my kid's got a painful uh
you know hand or finger he cut himself
I'm going to slap him off the side of
the head he'll feel better I don't think
that's what was going through his head
he wanted to make him feel worse so he
didn't go near the band saw without
being more cautious but it probably did
reduce the pain a little bit to some
extent now where it's key is oh my maybe
we'll get into it later with chronic
pain is in some chronic painful
conditions the CPM or the denck doesn't
work m like fibromyalgia being
one um so pain inhibits pain uh is
another Neuroscience concept related to
pain that's rather
cool well and I'm sorry I missed your
question to could you repeat noing you
answer the question and and uh expand it
on it in a in a completely surprising
and far more interesting way than I ever
anticipated so thank you I I'm betting
that 98% of people listening to this
including myself have never heard that
pain inhibits pain incredible let's go
back to heat and cold we briefly touched
on heat but let's talk about the use of
uh quote unquote therapeutic heat or
therapeutic cold a cold pack for a you
know a you know a bruise that really
aches or maybe even a break or a sprain
or heat you know the in the world of
sport physio cold is now heavily debated
localized cold is heavily debated you
know you get people saying things I
don't know if this is true that you know
it creates a sludging of the of the
fluids trying to head in and out of the
injury so cold is not as good as heat
heat allows for um the uh inclusion and
removal of waste products and you know
there are all sorts of Just So Stories
that people make up some of which might
be true I don't know but what do we know
about heat and cold as physiological
stimula in terms of their ability to
ameliorate to help pain because of
course if you get things hot enough or
you get them cold enough you can create
pain with heat or cold but let's assume
we're not getting to that level of heat
or cold and one is in pain um you know
when I was a kid we had a hot water
bottle that for times when we were sick
with something but sometimes you know if
I felt an ache on the side I'd put some
hot water in the hot water bottle lie on
that thing watch some cartoons i'
definitely felt better sure sure well
putting aside the Contemporary
controversies over the mechanisms you
described which are I think very real
and need to be sorted out traditionally
historically we tend to think of
applying cold for the first 48 hours or
so after an acute injury and then heat
thereafter cold has some really cool
effects cold uh reduces inflammation so
it reduces some of the release of those
inflammatory chemicals we talked about
prostaglandins cyto histamines um other
chemo kindes all these fancy terms for
substances that
sensitize the primary
Noor and it reduces the release of those
and it reduces inflammation another cool
thing often not appreciated is nerves
don't fire as fast when they're cold and
so if you've got no acceptors that are
firing and you put
cold it's slowing the number of signals
coming up and by definition it's
reducing the the the ultimately the pain
you're experiencing now heat heat has an
obvious effect of increasing blood flow
it's going to help uh relax muscles and
get blood into those muscles and that's
probably why you were putting that hot
water bottle on um and it just darn
feels good and so what what do I tell
people you know in part I tell people
use whichever works best for them um I
find there's huge individual
variability in whether people like heat
or like
cold and within
reason uh they're safe what do I mean
within reason don't go putting an ice
pack on an extremity for two hours you
know you'll get a
frostbite so you know take care with
that how cold should one make the point
on their body that's in pain assuming of
course that they're not going to give
themselves frostbite meaning do you want
to numb the area you know get past that
point point where it's a little bit
painful and then that you know basically
you're shutting down some neural
Pathways and you don't feel anything
there it's numb and then you let the
blood flow return When you remove the
cold pack is that I mean that's a
reasonable suggestion okay yeah all
right well people I think will
appreciate that the um the specifics of
that because um you know and of course
listeners of this podcast often are
interested in whole body deliberate cold
immersion you know cold showers ice
baths Etc most people experience those
as somewhat painful as they get into
them yeah and then can experience some
numbness when they get out is it
possible to raise one's pain threshold
through the regular exposure to pain in
ways that are safe such as deliberate
cold exposure assuming that one doesn't
stay in too long and it's not too cold
um and or through you know we were
talking about sports earlier but just in
general like can we raise our pain
threshold so that life is less painful
the short answer to your last question
is yes um the answer to your other
question about about uh extreme cold and
cold exposure which I know you have a
lot of expertise and you can teach me a
lot I'm going to stay in my wheelhouse
at because I I'm not up on the
literature in that space even in its
intersection with
pain um it's an intriguing concept uh I
have to
imagine that it makes sense you would
get some
habituation uh with that repeated
exposure I think one of the the
questions that would come up with for
instance the cold exposure Ure and I
don't know the answer to this but it's
I'm sure maybe somebody out there does
is is there cross
modality um changes in pain thresholds I
mean if you expose yourself a lot to
cold does it change your heat thresholds
I don't I would surprise be surprised if
it did yeah would or your pressure
because those are separate parallel
Pathways yeah yeah you know there uh and
you know as an aside I hate the cold but
I do really well with the heat you know
and so does Ian uh you know I think
there's something genetic there uh so
you know I mentioned earlier around men
and women and heat uh thresholds and I
chose that specifically but each of
these are different depending on the
stimulus
modality can you change ultimately your
thresholds yeah where that involves is a
lot of cognitive control it's a lot of
cognitive training uh around that
space
and you know there's there's clearly
approaches to that
people have learned that there's
different manipulations around that
so one experiment this wasn't intended
at least I don't believe so they were
measuring uh heat thresholds uh on
college students and and we we
experiment a lot on students as as we
all know we pay them well um and what
they found is that when they're studying
guys studying dudes when there was an
attractive woman who was delivering the
stimulus the thresholds were
higher because the guys did not want to
look like a wuss in front of this
attractive young woman and that's been
pretty well established so the
experimenter their
gender uh plays a big role in that has
the reverse experiment also been done I
don't I don't know I don't know
interesting um but getting back to your
point Point yes um I think through a
number of uh you know cognitive
manipulations you can ultimately um over
time change those thresholds another one
area is ex is movement
exercise you know clearly changes uh
those thresholds over time you are
probably building up um some increased
inhibitory tone through that process I'd
like to take a quick break and and thank
our sponsor insid tracker insid tracker
is a personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and
DNA to help you better understand your
body and help you reach your health
goals now I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done for the
simple reason that many of the factors
that impact your immediate and long-term
Health can only be analyzed from a
quality blood test a major problem with
a lot of blood tests out there however
is that you get information back about
metabolic factors lipids and hormones
and so forth but you don't know what to
do with that information with inside
tracker they make it very easy because
they have a personalized platform that
allows you to see the levels of all
those things metabolic factors lipids
hormones Etc but it gives you specific
directives that you can follow that
relate to nutrition behavioral
modifications supplements Etc that can
help you bring those numbers into the
ranges that are optimal for you if you'd
like to try insid tracker you can go to
insid tracker.com huberman to get 20%
off any of insid tracker's plans again
that's insidetracker
docomo one thing I'm fascinated by in
the whole mindfulness space yeah uh is
this idea of whether or not under
conditions of stress or in this case
pain whether or not the most adaptive
mindset assuming it's not a tissue
damaging level of pain would be to think
about something else distract oneself
from the pain or conversely whether or
not one should quote unquote go into the
pain so for people who have chronic pain
Maybe it's in a a small area of the body
that experiences chronic pain pain quite
often AK chronic pain or maybe it's
whole body pain I don't think it really
matters for the question I'm asking and
people are trying to develop some
cognitive ways so what we call as
neuroscientists you and I top down
mechanisms for like okay I'm going to
distract myself from the pain I'm going
to focus on other things I really enjoy
or rather I'm going to really go into
the pain meet the pain and realize I
don't know somehow that it's not as bad
like somehow there's a and again this
becomes very opaque right we don't
really know what we're talking about
when we when we do these sorts of
protocols but those sorts of things are
out there in the mindfulness space and I
think um I certainly take mindfulness
seriously as as an intervention but what
always bothers me about those sorts of
interventions is that they lack the
specificity and the granularity and
there's no kind of mechanistic logic to
explain them so what what are your
thoughts on on meeting the pain versus
distracting oneself from the pain let's
break that down because there's two
concepts there as you alluded to and
they're both effective and they both
work
differently so one is attentional
distraction where you are distracting
yourself from the thing that is causing
pain clearly works in a lot of
people and that's why one of the
strategies that we recommend for
patients for people living with pain is
to engage in distracting activities read
a book um uh go for a walk um spend time
with friends and family in particular in
the community and work to get your mind
off of pain what we've learned is it
that attentional distraction engages
specific brain networks they tend to be
some of the outer layer of brain
networks in your prefrontal cortex some
in your singulate cortex
um in other regions which are clearly
involved with distraction it's not
necessarily that distraction is going to
completely eliminate one's pain but it
can reduce it uh significantly and this
is
why the
biggest problem with distraction from a
time of the day is at
night it's when people are trying to
sleep during the daytime you can read
that book you can spend time with
friends and family but people with
chronic pain that have it 24
seven you can't distract yourself at
night when you're trying to get into a
relaxed State and fall asleep and that's
why sleep is such a big issue for people
with chronic pain so attentional
distraction it it works distraction
works now what you said I mean the
second piece you said kind of let's meet
the pain if you will and there's
different approaches to meeting the
pain one approach that you invoked with
mindfulness is
is addressing the pain from a
non-judgmental accepting
manner I'm aware the pain is there I am
not going to judge it I'm not going to
put a value on it's bad it's good or
anything I'm just going to note its
presence and that has been shown to work
as well in fact actually when John kabat
Zen originally developed
mindfulness-based stress reduction
people with low back
pain PL Studies have shown that it works
I've completed just some recent studies
in
mbsr uh as well and we're diving deeply
into the data so it's this
non-judgmental acceptance if you will of
the pain sorry mbsr is the acronym for
mindfulness based stress reduction
mbsr everybody should do mbsr let me be
C I have no Financial relationship with
any of this by the way but
mindfulness-based stress reduction has
been shown effective for anxiety for
depression for pain just about
everything I think they should put it
into all the
schools uh it's it's a great skill to
learn no side effects takes a little bit
of time to learn
it and uh it can be in some people
effective and helpful for pain and
that's the key that we're going to keep
coming back to is some of these things
work for some of the people some of the
time there's a third aspect of meeting
the
pain and that is more of a
direct cognitive reframing about the
meaning of the pain
now you're coming at the pain and you
have um an approach you're making effort
on what you're thinking of the
pain is that pain damaging threatening
harmful or do you view it as yeah it
hurts but it's not harming
me that is a critical
critical aspect of pain management and
that is serves as a foundation for
something called cognitive behavioral
therapy the the cool thing about a
number of these is that there's actually
different neural circuits
engaged with these different
approaches and um I think the key that
we have to figure out and this is where
research is going is which approach
works for which person under which
circumstance so interesting uh something
you said about understanding the pain
but not um overinterpreting or
catastrophizing the pain seems important
knowing the difference between being
hurt or feeling hurt versus being
injured has been something that's been
important to me I've been involved in
sports uh where clearly pain was
involved it's like I'm hurt but am I
injured that's the first question you
know like I've rolled an ankle like oh
you know like I'm limping this hurts am
I injured meaning am I going to be back
at it in an hour tomorrow versus I've
broken bones and it's you know you know
great empathy for anybody that does like
when you're injured you feel the snap
and you know you're out for a while in
some cases um so I think knowing the
difference between being hurt and being
injured is something that's kind of that
key moment and for me it's always been
experienced as a moment of anxiety after
feeling pain especially in a sports year
like uh oh like am I am I going to have
to take two weeks off or is this just
pain so I think for people to be able to
recognize when pain is reporting an
injury versus when pain is just
reporting a temporary sensation is
really important and perhaps also for
psychological hurt versus psychological
injury I mean that gets to some larger
context themes these days of somebody
says something it upsets us are we hurt
or are we injured right you know I think
it gets very
murky how does one determine if they are
hurt versus injured and then maybe we
could even stretch into the
psychological realm neither of us are
psychologists but it sounds like so much
of what you do represents the the bridge
from the body into the mind and so you'd
be remiss if we didn't talk about
emotional pain as well yeah so what you
just said your spot your spot on Andrew
and that one of the key messages the key
you know macky's tips for pain
management is to understand the
distinction between hurt versus
harm versus harm MH
critical absolutely critical let me
allow me to illustrate with
um patient I saw won't name names some
time ago guys's in his 40 is a master's
level tennis player tennis is his life
he's works as some executive somewhere
but he lives for tennis comes hobbling
in on
crutches sits down and he's got pain in
his foot and he was told not to put
pressure on his foot because he's got
this injury and it's going to be worse
and this has been going on now for
months and he's now depressed because he
can't play tennis tennis is his life
this guy's life is tennis so I examine
this guy and it turns out what he has is
something called a Morton's neuroma and
a Morton's neuroma is a fibrous
thickening of tissue around the nerves
that go to your toes and it gets to be
like this bundled tissue nerves and it's
really
painful um it's very
painful but it's not causing
harm there's no harm there it's really
painful so I explain this to the guy and
he looks at me with like this light bulb
goes off and he's like you mean I can
play
tennis and I'm like yeah guy you can go
play all the you want it's just going to
hurt he got up he left the crutches in
the exam office and he walked
away now that's an extreme example I
don't want people please to think that
that kind of thing occurs all the time
it doesn't um chronic pain conditions
are often incredibly complicated and
need much more than you know a 45 minute
or 60-minute education session and you
know back to the tennis court he still
had pain in his foot by the
way but he could play but that gives
that example of
addressing that fear and the anxiety
around that that issue and I think
that's what we first have to learn is
does that pain that we're experiencing
represent something that is harming us
that something that we either need to
seek a medical attention now or sometime
soon and whether does continued
activity worsen the tissue injury or not
in my world where I'm caring mostly for
people with chronic
pain we've moved beyond the tissue
healing by definition by one of the
definitions for chronic pain is that the
pain
persists beyond the time of tissue
healing so in many of our sessions our
times we're educating people hurt versus
harm it's back pain we we evaluate the
spine we make sure is the spine stable
is there anything Sinister causing
damage in most of the cases it's not and
we help people understand that
distinction critical critical for
people and yet at the same time you
don't want to just ignore
something that is a real medical issue
that's getting worse and needs medical
attention and that's where the
complexity of all this comes in did I
answer your question yeah beautifully I
think this distinction between hurt
versus harmed is so important for people
to hear um perhaps you're willing to
expand a little bit in terms of the
psychological hurt versus harmed I mean
I'm not asking you to comment on um
societal or generational shifts but you
know we'd be avoiding the obvious if we
didn't say that in the last um really 10
to 15 years there's been a pretty
dramatic shift in terms of how Society
at large interprets emotional pain right
people hearing things or seeing things
and the idea that emotional pain could
be related to physical pain or at least
similar enough to it that people's
emotional pain is valid right and if
anything I'm here to validate the fact
that emotional pain is valid like any
other pain except it is different
because it becomes very hard to point
to a specific kind of threshold we're
using that word a lot today but I think
it's appropriate here threshold between
hurt and harmed whereas if I tell you
that my left foot hurts which it did a
lot in high school and then you took an
x-ray of my foot in high school you'd
say your foot's broken because it was
broken a lot in high school and that's
harmed I mean to continue to do what I
was doing to break it in the first place
I was harm clearly going to harm myself
worse so I had to had to heal up but
when it comes to psycholog iCal pain you
know Psychiatry has all these thresholds
for normal functioning versus abnormal
functioning are you sleeping well normal
relationship and on and on we don't want
to go there because that's not our place
but how do you when you see patients how
do you take into account the level or
the thresholds for their emotional pain
because that's part of your job so I'm
asking you this from the perspective of
a somebody who treats pain how do you
gauge somebody's psychological pain is
it by how intensely they vocal ize their
pain or does it always go back to how
well or poorly their life is being
managed at the level of sleep nutrition
relationships and so forth yeah great
great set of questions there's a lot in
there let me first start off with
something very
simple I don't try to distinguish
between this notion of psychological
pain physical pain it's pain and of and
of I think once I get into where you get
into this trying to distinguish is this
psychological pain or psychogenic pain
which was a terrible term or physical
pain you end up putting value judgments
on people and I don't think it serves us
well when we're caring for the person in
front of us if they're in pain I'm
addressing the pain the thing to note is
at least in people that come into our at
Stanford Pain Management Center and
other pain centers is that remember pain
is a sensory and emotional experience
it's all wrapped up and so we want to
treat the whole
person sometimes we get we get easy we
get easy ones and we just go do a nerve
block and pain goes away and that's
simple but usually it's much more
complex where we're seeing the
interaction
of uh an expression of pain that
includes includes a significant amount
of anxiety of depression you mentioned
this term catastrophizing which we can
break down if you'd like and that's
probably one of the biggest
predictors factors in uh in
amplification of pain and worsening pain
and poor treatment response is
catastrophizing um I try to treat the
whole person and not really partial out
all this I do at Stanford I you I built
a digital Health System that captures
measures a lot of data around a
patient's experience across physical
psychological and social functioning and
we use that
data to Target therapies to understand
um how much their depressive symptoms
are anxiety anger anger big issue in
pain huge in pain does it make it worse
or better invariably it makes it worse
yeah and you know you can break anger
down in a couple different categories
John Burns and others has broken it into
like anger in versus anger out I don't
know if that term is familiar with
you um anger out that's my
father um loud loud angry
boisterous banging you know would
quickly turn anything into an angry
tiate anger out expressive yelling at
the at the news yes yelling at somebody
who cuts you off in traffic usually
yelling at the man uh cuz he hated job
um anger
in boiling simmering you know
self-contained
seething that's anger
in data seems to support anger in is is
worse it's bad so it's not necessarily
whether or not it's directed at someone
external in both cases anger in and
anger out can be directed at someone
external it's a question of whether or
not it's expressed outwardly or
contained inside beautifully stated
beautifully stated so we C you know
anger depression anxiety uh we capture
fatigue sleep and so what we try to do
is again look at the whole person
because they're not just a back if
that's where they're having pain or not
just a neck or a shoulder in your case
it's impacting the whole person and we
just got done talking earlier about how
all of these circuits interact with each
other and so sometimes we can't just
eliminate the no susception in the
periphery sometimes we can reduce it but
what we have to do is Target everything
and we have to try to Target all these
circuits up here and in many cases what
we're doing is through education through
pain
psychology um through physical therapy
and re rehabilitative approaches on top
of it and yes the medications we have
now you know we touched Bas on a few
earlier but we have over 200 medications
available for pain um very few of them
FDA approved
uh we tend to steal from all the other
fields so you're talking about more than
200 medications that can be yes
prescribed for pain but as off Lael
treatments perfectly stated yeah there's
only a few medications that are actually
FDA approved specifically for pain so
what we what we do is we borrow or steal
from the psychiatrists some of their uh
their
anti-depressants uh which will
frequently work very effectively for
pain and work on those pain related
circuits in the
brain we uh take from the neurologist
some of the anti-seizure medications
because those
medications um while reducing separately
seizures for people who don't have
seizures they work on ION channels um
they work on other neuromodulators that
also are involved in pain circuitry we
can take from the cardiologist
medications that work on the heart anti-
arhythmia or heart rhythm drugs they are
potent sodium channel blockers and the
sodium channels as you know are
responsible for the action potential
that generates the nerve impulse signal
and so they're like an oral local
anesthetic that you take and so we we we
take from everybody in our field in the
medications getting back to to what you
said
so just summarizing one I I don't really
distinguish
uh psychological versus physical pain in
my world I I find it better just to
treat it as pain and look at the person
holistically and go after all the
components at once I find that's where
we get the best
results and it is typically bringing a
lot of tools to Bear speaking of tools
to Bear What role if any does nutrition
play in local or whole body pain I
critical and I think we're learning more
and more and more
about uh the role of good nutrition of
healthy eating anti-inflammatory diets
uh avoidance of foods that are
triggers
um and an incredibly underappreciated
area
um you know I've had my experiences with
chronic pain um
I developed uh an abdominal chronic pain
problem uh shortly after I turned 50 I
was throwing a happy hour for our pain
psychologists of all people went to a
Mexican restaurant I won't name which
one got food poisoning That's why I'm
not naming it good Mexican food bad food
poisoning and ever since that event I
can't eat anything in the onion family
what um I'm familiar with with onions
but what else is in the onion family I'm
sure you've researched this now pretty
thoroughly considering what you're
describing classic and the what we refer
to as fod Maps you know it's one of the
fod maps and I have now some issues with
the others and um manifested by just
severe severe up abdominal pain and um
not many other symptoms but you know it
put me on this journey where uh severe
abdominal pain didn't know why couldn't
sleep
couldn't sleep went like I'd go months
without having a restful night's sleep I
thought I was getting early Alzheimer's
because I felt like I was getting
stupid and um what actually benefited me
was of all things the pandemic why
because what did we all do we isolated
we started eating the same foods and I
started noticing I was feeling better
when I was eating certain foods my
abdominal pain went away and I'd start
doing as a scientist
experiments and I finally was was able
to isolate and determine what the
problem
was so now I have complete avoidance on
that I'm I'm a little difficult to go
out to a restaurant and have dinner but
you know so no onions no onions and what
else shallots chives scallions leaks
anything in the onion family you know
not alium I'm fine with
garlic
and you know by healthy eating by
identifying something by triggers
changed my life
and return to a degree of normaly I
think the key for people is you know if
you have any kind of similar issues
identify those
triggers sometimes uh isolation of you
know Foods or restrictions and using a
journal and then as you learn from that
slowly build Foods back into your diet I
think it's so important for people to
hear this and thanks for sharing your
personal story around this because I
think that nutrition while every
physician seems to appreciate that the
quality of nutrition matters defining
what quality nutrition is is really
difficult there's still you know Avid
even we could call them ranous debates
about this you know vegan versus
omnivore versus this and you know but it
sounds like this is a case where it can
become very individualized but I could
imagine somebody going to their
physician and that physician not being
you and saying yeah you know I notice
that when I eat certain foods I'm in a
lot of pain and the physician simply
saying well don't eat those foods but
unless that person is a trained
scientist like not knowing how to go
about doing the sorts of experiments
that you did would be difficult
impossible I'm sorry I know I interrupt
you I just want to build on that if I if
I can one of the key things I simplified
my story but the key thing is is if I if
I eat onions or anything that onion
family it's pain for two weeks wow it is
so the thing is
is if you get repeated Expos exposures
it never stops and it gets very very
hard to figure out what it was so it's
not like you eat something you get pain
it goes away where you know we can all
do that pattern recognition here you
have to be able to think back what
happened two weeks ago that may have
influenced it so it's not easy well this
may be a case for elimination diets
which are uh provide they're done safely
where people restrict the number of
foods they eat to a very limited number
of foods make sure they still get enough
calories and macronutrients uh that they
need protein fats and carbohydrates or
what what have you but that by limiting
the total number of foods that they eat
to like eight or 10 basic things then
you can build things in and then explore
what triggers the pain or what removes
the pain I don't really see any other
way I am intrigued by The Onion example
even though it's a it's a it's your case
in particular and we don't want to
extrapolate too broadly is there
something about onions that's triggering
a particular neurochemical or immune
pathway
do we have any knowledge of like why
onions would create that kind of gut
pain this has been a journey I've been
on now for a few years to answer this um
uh one of our GI pain docks that we have
come in the Clin lyen newwin sent me a
paper from I know Sellar nature that
showed that after a gut
infection it can change the genetic
expression related to sensitizing you to
food antigens I know I throw out a lot
of jargon there basically the short
answer is you get an infection and your
gut no longer
responds properly to a normal food
item and so one explanation may be I got
this infection I was at a Mexican
restaurant a lot of onions and I got
sensitized through that infection now
subsequently to onions you know I saw a
Stanford uh allergist Hannah Watford
who's awesome by the way and uh after I
had this I think figured out and I went
in and I'm like well you know Dr Watford
is there anything I can do for this and
she laughed and she's like no you're
doing everything it's all just
avoidance and I thinking I was rather
unique and special about this thing I
said you know do you ever see this and
she said oh yeah I see this all the time
every day I see this all the time and I
said like this isn't unusual he's like
no I see this thing all the time and
this thing meaning sensitivity stivity
to certain know to certain to different
these different food groups and this
this thing that occurs later in life
something an event that happens to
somebody that
triggers and I said well gosh that
sounds like a public health problem and
she's like that's what we're debating
right now in the allergy Community is
whether this is representing more of a
public health issue and is because I'm
seeing I Dr Watford I'm seeing
increasing amounts of this uh as we go
forward how interesting well um this is
not a time to plug the philanthropic arm
of our premium podcast but uh I'm very
involved in science philanthropy this
sounds like an area to De devote some
funding to to explore how foods are
impacting the local and systemic pain
response yeah I I got in you know so I'm
running a large biomarker study to
characterize people deeply and one of
the things that I wanted to put in there
is microbiome characterization now to be
clear that's out of my wheelhouse but
the beauty of being at Stanford and
other major institutions is you can go
make friends yeah Justin sonenberg who's
been a guest on this podcast is one of
the world experts on the gut microbiome
we have a few others too so there you go
so he's a friendly guy I'm sure he'll
collaborate we go we go make friends and
people who understand the microbiome we
collect the samples and that's where
team science is magical and once again
the idea looking at the whole
person as long as we're talking about
the gut um let's talk about pain inside
the body because we talked about NOS
acceptors on the surface of the body and
the pain that most people uh immediately
think of when you have a discussion
about pain is you know pain on the
surface or a broken bone or maybe hip
pain or knee pain or back pain but what
about pain that resides deeper in the
visera you know uh gut pain um irritable
bowel syndrome these things are I'm
learning are far more uh common than um
that I knew I'm fortunate that um if I
have a stomach ache or a headache it
means something's wrong I rarely get
those I've sometimes been called you
know have a stomach of Steel not because
it's hard from the outside um but
because I can eat pretty much anything
although I eat pretty cleanly a lot of
people write to me and ask questions on
social media about irritable bowel
syndrome and other forms of gut pain and
viscera pain like pain that they feel is
really deep within their system
typically how is that sort of pain dealt
with at a clinical level absolutely
visceral pain is a different thing than
what we been describing uh a lot of
which is sematic Pain by the way I'll
say as an aside I used to have a gut of
Steel also I could Chomp down anything
anytime anywhere and so you know there
was a lot of grief and loss associated
with not being able to eat certain foods
and uh that's also something people have
to come to grips with um but getting
back to visceral pain so the thing about
setic pain that's another term now itic
meaning the Soma the the the extremity
that you are alluding to is the no
acceptors there uh very precisely
localize where the stimulus the painful
stimulus is coming from when you hit
your thumb with a hammer you know
exactly where that pain occurred with
the visceral pain what you have are very
diffuse what we refer to as receptive
fields think about you last time you had
a stomach ache it's not that you put
your thumb right here you said is kind
of hurts like this your whole stomach
whole stomach it's because those
receptive fields are very large they're
broad they're not as well localized and
in part the reason for that type of
broad receptive field is you're not
trying to get away from localized
danger so when people get stomach AES
it's often a very Broad Brad area when
you get pelvic pain it's the same type
of thing
now there's some fascinating stuff that
occurs with visceral pain because those
fibers that extend from the viscera
meaning the the lungs the abdomen the
pelvis they all head into the spinal
cord
too and it just so happens that they
make kind of indirect direct connections
with the same
level that represents the
body
so let's think about pelvic pain for
instance you frequently will find people
that said that have pelvic pain that
will describe having lower back pain
too and it's because of this visceral
somatic convergence in the spinal cord
it's not that there's something going on
in their back it's that these signals
that are being driven heavily from the
pelvis are coming in and connecting with
the same regions from the
back and the convergence of that is now
being perceived as pain in
both and we we were seeing that more and
more in the research this viscerosomatic
convergence people have pain in their
pelvis and then also over their abdomen
um classic one that uh we're aware of we
see this in the TV the movies and
unfortunately real life are heart attack
so the visceral fibers that subserve the
heart typically the first through the
fourth thoracic region well those
converge um in the spinal cord in
similar regions that subserve sensation
under the arm and up here that's why
people will often say they've got pain
with a heart attack radiating down into
their arm the left arm typically the
left arm the heart is on the left side
exactly
um after people get abdominal
surgery Sometimes some blood can leak
out and it'll slip underneath the
diaphragm the diaphragm is subserved by
some of those neck regions three four
and five of the cervical which happens
to also cover your shoulder and so
you'll get people after abdominal
surgery they said man my shoulder's
really hurting me
Doc and what we do is we first check to
see you know could something have
happened during an you know during
placement just make sure there's nothing
wrong but frequently it's due to
irritation that's again one of the
magical Mysteries it's so fascinating
about
pain it seems like a good point to bring
up referenced pain um or is what you're
describing an example of referenced pain
so my understanding of referenced pain
is that you know like for instance I
I've got a slight bulge at I think like
my lumbar 34 disc or something I had a
whole body scan recently just a um an
exploration scan cuz I had the
opportunity not not anything serious
fortunately and there's a slightly bulg
disc there and every once in a while if
I do certain movements um in the gym
I'll get pain down in my right hip and
sometimes going down my leg and I used
to think it was sciatica cuz you assume
anything on the right back side okay
must be wallet induced s sciatica back
pocket wallet into sciatica um but what
I eventually realized is that well it's
this dis buul it just so happens that
the nerves that emit from that that
region um they Branch out to a bunch of
different areas and so you think the
pain is in your leg but the the issue is
someplace else or um and occasionally
indeed I feel the pain elsewhere in my
body as well it's sort of like a like a
matching of regions for pain that seem
unrelated is that a way to think about
reference pain perfectly the the the
examples also I referred to of a heart
attack causing referred pain or also the
pelvic region associated with back pain
as a way of um referred pain um what
you're describing is the fact that pain
doesn't have to start with an injury or
a stimulus in the periphery you could
damage the nerves anywhere along the way
and that will be perceived as pain we
refer to that as neuropathic pain so
that's another distinction you brought
up uh nicely good good segue into
there's thought to be um several
different types or categories of pain we
have been talking through much of this
time about somatic pain you know injury
out here we talked about visceral pain
and when you have damage to a peripheral
nerve damage injury to a peripheral
nerve or the central nervous system we
refer to that as neuropathic pain
it frequently has different qualities
different characteristics people will
refer to it as shooting stabbing shock
like
burning it can frequently uh when
there's a damage to a nerve or damage to
certain regions of the brain be
incredibly challenging to
treat by the way the good news is with
that uh light disc bulge is the vast
majority of time the discs reabsorb yeah
I have to be careful to not do too much
um
spinal flexion like sit-ups and stuff I
thought that that would help but that
actually doesn't strengthen the back it
was actually a asymmetry between the
abdominal muscles and the lower back
muscles so provided I do a lot of back
extension type training then that bulge
more or less stays in I just have to be
a little little cautious not too
cautious fortunately as long as we're
talking about referenced pain somatic
visceral and all the rest what about
associative or referenced pain where
it's psychological and I don't want to
get too abstract here but more and more
these days I hear from people who say
you know I was in this job and the job
sucked or I was in this relationship and
the relationship sucked and I had
terrible back pain like really acute
localized back pain or chronic headaches
or migraines yeah and then they go on
vacation or they change their
circumstances and lo and behold the pain
goes away does that surprise you as an
expert in pain not at all not at all
what you're you know simp simplistically
referring to is you know there's people
are undergoing
stress and we
have we clearly know that the brain is
not a passive recipient of information
coming in from the body it's a two-way
street the brain is causing Downstream
consequences in the body the brain uh
controls our sympathetic nervous system
and parasympathetic nervous system the
sympathetic being the fight andlight
response it controls the tone of uh
cortisol that's being released and we
all know that in acute
situations rapid increases of cortisol
and um nor adrenaline is keeps us away
from the Lions and the Tigers and the
bears oh my but in a chronic situation
and uh Robert spolski as you know at
Stanford has built a career around
chronic stress at least in part and very
bad for us and so these chronic
stressors impact the end organ the
tissue and it's real pain it doesn't
mean that we need to go get back
surgery it means that probably we need
to identify the stressors that are
contributing to that and address those
and we'll often find that in the
scenarios you outline that the pain gets
better um some of those targets are
interesting um there's a lot of memory
associated with pain this is where early
life events
occur and those early life events and
injuries can sensitize us to Future
vulnerability so I was in a car act bad
car accident when I was
16 uh fortunate to walk away from it got
bad whiplash
if I get stressed a lot of my pain
manifests in my
neck for me as a pain do it's a signal
to me that's
like go work out go for a walk in the
forest you know uh and take some time
away from the
computer again that's a simplistic
message and my experience doesn't
translate into everybody else but I'm
just validating every everything that
you you
said let's consider the opposite
scenario which is positive emotions uh
you've done some very nice studies
exploring how being in positive
relationships being in love in fact can
change our perception that is our
experience of pain and probably does so
at real physiological levels as you
mentioned earlier psychological is
physiological and vice versa it's hard
to separate the two but could you share
with us uh what you did in that study
and what you found because I find it
really interesting and it also points to
the incredible power of love in uh how
we
experience life yeah yeah I think
there's several cool things about that
study that I love to share one is how it
all came about so um you know us
Neuroscience Geeks often go to the
society for Neuroscience as an annual
meeting and I was hanging out and uh
sharing a room with art Aaron who
studies passionate love and he and his
wife study passionate love and we were
having a glass or two of wine and I'm
asking art have you ever you know have
you ever studied pain he's like no I
study love and he's like have you ever
studied love no I study pain if has
anybody ever studied the intersection
another glass of wine no let's do it so
we came back to Stanford and there was a
young postto Jared younger who's now a
professor at the University of Alabama
and I said Jared we were either going to
fall flat in her face or we're going to
this is going to be a cool study and
Jared took this on great job so what we
did is we advertised on campus for
couples in an early phase of a romantic
relationship
because there's a reason for choosing
that in an early phase of a romantic
relationship you are deeply focused on
your beloved they're on your mind all
the time you feel great when you're with
them you feel terrible when you're not
with them doesn't that just sound like
an
addiction I mean it's that yearning uh I
don't know that's it's a can be a
pleasant experience but addictions you
know for the people who are using the
substance can find it you know in that
early phase very pleasant but it it
turns out that the early phase of a
romantic relationship engages the same
neural circuitries as addiction
interesting same reward circuitry all
that so we chose that and so he said
come to us and bring pictures of your
beloved and bring pictures of an equally
attractive acquaintance clothed this
isn't sex that we're studying uh
clothed and we caused them pain in the
scanner and and and we paid them
afterwards um we
needed a control condition for this
because thinking about your
beloved is very uh attentionally
demanding remember we talked about
attentional distraction earlier so we
gave people what's called a word
generation
task very simply um can you think about
every sport that doesn't involve a
ball okay uh frisbee hockey boxing
boxing okay that's attentionally
demanding think about every vegetable
that's not green and you know so you're
running that through your head and we're
causing you pain it's an intentional
distraction task
so we flash people pictures of their
beloved cause pain flash people of their
acquaintance cause pain and then
distraction okay what did we find love
works great love works great it was a
wonderful analgesic it significantly
reduced people's
pain and it turned out the more in love
you were the more pain relief you got
when viewing the photo of the person you
love yes when View doing the photo of
the person you love now how did we know
how much in love they were it turns out
the psychologists have got scales for
everything and one of them is a
passionate love scale which asks how
what percentage of the day are you
preoccupied thinking about your beloved
oh goodness you just sent people now off
to give their Partners the passionate
love scale to figure out how much time
they're spending thinking about them
yeah we we had Stanford students some of
them thinking about their beloved 80% of
the day uh I wanted to use this as a
screening tool for our resident
applicants because uh I I I want them
focusing on patients not their beloved
and that is by the way a joke that bad
joke but but probably is real world
we're not just talking about Stanford I
mean but when somebody's writing you a
script or a prescription that is or
giving you advice um yeah you might want
to know if they are in a new romantic
relationship yeah so the the the other I
thought the other uh cool thing about
this study was attention worked also but
attention
and love worked on different
circuits so attentional distraction they
worked equally well attention again
worked on some of these prefrontal
regions these outer cortical
areas love worked on more of what we
classically think of is these
reward-based circuits the nucleus
accumbens uh the amydala
um one of the the descending uh brain
stem regions called the substantia
which is coming down from the brain
through that area to the spinal cord to
inhibit pain so classic addiction
Pathways classic and so the key again
message for people is um different what
we would think of as psychological
approaches engaging different brain
circuits to reduce
pain I'll leave you with one last uh
side note that we didn't publish on and
that is uh Jared went back a year later
and we assessed the student strength of
their relationship if assuming it was
still ongoing and he found that there
was a rather High correlation between
the love induced analgesia and brain
activity and the cadate nucleus and in
the insular with the strength of their
relationship a year later it was so we
had a brain scan that was a predictor a
future um strength of a relationship
could you tell us the direction of those
results so if a new romantic partnership
is uh creating high levels of activity
in these two brain areas you just
mentioned then it is a very good
predictor that the relationship will yes
survive over time well in this limited
sample it meant that it it was going to
be very strong a year later um
understand and you know Andrew we always
have to put these caveats unpublished
non-peer reviewed it was a fun post Haw
data analysis that I'm not sure if
anybody's ever you know run with those
kind of things no but we can explore it
in a in a playful way now and people can
do with it what they will it does sort
of speak to something important though
um assuming that result would hold up if
the same experiment were done and you
know many hundreds or thousands of
people it sort of speaks to the idea
that the activation of these addiction
likee circuits in the early phase of a
passionate love
relationship set in motion
a certain number of things that create
stability in that relationship which on
the face of it um makes sense but we've
also all heard of the opposite way of
well as well which is you know um Fools
Rush In or that uh things that start
fast end fast or things like that but
here you're talking about um the early
phase of passion serving this
interesting role in terms of analgesia
uh alleviating pain but also predicting
some stability of the relationship over
time it's kind of interesting it's
fascinating to talk about uh you know I
feel like I have to put that caveat in
that not generalized but a fun thing to
talk about and it's where I think cool
scientific ideas can come from for
future exploration that I think that's
also what's pretty neat
um I find the um you know again the
different circuits for different
approaches to reducing pain fascinating
again that gets to the question you
asked me earlier is there one circuit
and the answer is no what we have to do
is figure out what is the best circuit
for a particular person or set of
circuits if you're willing I'd like to
talk about
opioids first if you could educate us on
endogenous opioids the opioids that we
make inside of our body that we don't
that meaning nobody takes as a drug and
then how that informs opioids that
people take I mean clearly the so-called
opioid crisis is a concern many people
addicted to opioids people have died
from taking too many opioids but
presumably some people have benefited
from these opioid drugs as well so would
like to talk about that and then I'd
like to also talk about some of the um
things that are adjacent to the
prescription opioids things like katum
which right now are being sort of called
into question as to whether or not they
will continue to be legally available
over the caler so first and foremost
what are the endogenous opioids how do
they work and and that I think will set
the stage for the rest yeah so we all
have these endogenous and keyins and
endorphins that um act as painkillers
they are uh analgesics they are natural
substances and all of us that get
expressed uh there is a certain
endogenous tone to these that some have
uh done research on here again Jared did
research on this and Steven Bru and
others on showing that higher endogenous
opioid levels May um you know lead to
less emotional reactivity for
instance um thank God we you know we
have endogenous opioids or you know we
just couldn't handle it um what chemists
have figured out is how
to you know bring in exogenous opioids
and morphine was the prototypical one uh
from the from the poppy and since then
medicinal chemists have built on
variations of morphine and created other
compounds some again variations on
morphine some are purely synthetic like
the oxycodone could I ask a question
because I'm fascinated by the history of
these things how did or when and or when
did somebody look at the poppy and then
say Oh I'm going to start eating poppies
or isolating things from poppies and
realize that that morphine thousands of
years ago okay so poppies have been used
for a very long time long long time
these things have been around um so this
is uh this is old school work that's
only been refined in more contemporary
history and the whole topic of opioids
is such an incredibly controversial area
and I I feel like I have
to you know you have to understand the
speaker my in this case me my you know
one's position on this um my usual
Mantra is I am not pro- opioid I am not
anti-opioid I am Pro patient
so I have seen opioids positively
transform people's lives help them get
back to work spend time with friends and
family relieve suffering particularly in
situations um end of life but also in
people with chronic pain and I have seen
opioids destroy lives at a personal
level I come from a family background
deep deep in addiction I have lost close
loved family members
to addiction and I'm respectful of
that what I've learned is to not get
into this binary mode of thinking it's
either this or it's this but to treat
opioids as a
clinician as a tool to be used in
certain circumstances in some people not
typically as a Frontline or first line
agent
um typically much later down if they
have failed other
therapies you cannot approach the
challenge of
opioids uh without appreciating the Deep
complexity that we're faced with
particularly now in society with all of
the the litigation ongoing and all the
the money involved um it's uh it's a
highly nuanced topic so what what what
more would you like to talk about
opioids well I think that most people
hear about the opioid crisis and just
assume that they are quote unquote
overprescribed that people are given
opioid drugs as a Frontline treatment
perhaps more than they should that the
addictive component which I understand
is very real that the potential for
addiction is very real um as well as the
potential for
um cross interactions with other things
like alcohol
um and perhaps even other illicit drugs
you know street drugs perhaps if like if
people can't fill their
prescriptions um and tolerance to the
opioids creating issues where people
then need more of them they're do I have
a not close family member but a a you
know distant family member who had his
entire life in arranged beautifully it
was a practicing lawyer with a beautiful
wife and family had a back injury uh was
Pres cribed oxy conton it it helped him
initially but then it it set off some
behavioral psychological Pathways that
had him seeking more forging
prescriptions when you know he
understood the law he was a lawyer he
eventually went to jail got out the same
thing happened again he eventually ended
up dead right so and I think there are
many examples of that that we hear about
and those are very Salient and very
disturbing very
saddening so I think that most people
including myself hear the opioid crisis
and assume that what we really should be
doing is Seeking a better alternative
but what I'm hearing from you is that
there are use cases where opioids make a
great deal of sense and that they've
really helped improve people's lives and
that none of what I just described or
anything like it is experienced by those
people in fact quite the opposite do I
have that right perfectly and and that's
again
where we we we need to treat these at an
individual level on a case-by Case basis
um and that one size doesn't fit all um
yes opioids were
overprescribed I think everybody agrees
to that in this
country um and we went through a period
of time with massive overprescribing and
there's a lot of nuance and reasons why
in large part um Physicians we get
terrible education around pain and we
don't know how to treat it in general
coming out of medical school we get
about 7 hours of education on pain uh
veterinarians get 40 it's great if
you're taking I think your dog's name is
Castello yeah unfortunately he passed
but he took some pain meds for a short
while but I found an alternative
treatment that worked far better perfect
which turned out to be by the way lowd
do testosterone he was castrated like he
was fixed when he was younger um and I
it's interesting i' I've gone I've said
publicly on very large scale podcasts
that I gave my dog lowdose testosterone
later in life and it ameliorated a lot
of his aches and pains at least from
what I understood because he started
moving better and feeling better and
sleeping better and I expected the veter
community to come after me with
pitchforks not one wow did that and yet
I heard from hundreds of veterinarians
that said yes we wish that we could
prescribe those sorts of things to
people who castrate their male dogs
later in life to humiliate their
symptoms um so that opened up to me a
whole world of understanding about some
of the restrictions that vet that vets
face in terms of what they prescribe
there's a whole discussion to be had
about that we'll do a series on animal
and pet health vet Health great well the
Vets hopefully are healthy too you get
the point yeah but when it comes to the
opioid crisis in this discussion you
know I think it's become so Laden with
the idea that like doctors are on the
take like they're getting paid to give
opioids to patients and that's why
they're doing that and and I don't
believe that necessarily be the case but
I think that's what the public
perception is that it's all Financial
here's the here's the thing um were
there bad docks doing bad things yes um
I'm going to invoke uh a good friend of
mine Keith humph at St oh yeah terrific
terrific um psychologist who's an
addiction medicine uh psychologist and
public policy person and the way he
breaks it down and I subscribe to this
is you know the there's three types of
Physicians remember there's about a
million physicians in this country about
a
million um you've got Physicians doing
the right thing for the right reasons
vast majority of
docs we need to leave them alone we need
to support them we need to help them do
their job and not put more obstructions
in their way there is a much smaller
group of docs doing the wrong thing for
the right reasons what I mean by that is
these are docs who did overprescribe
opioids in this case in this
context they um did buy into the
marketing messages that were put forward
they did not have much education around
Alternatives in treating
pain and they thought by handing out
pills just pills uh in their very brief
visits with patients remember Primary
Care dox as my heart goes out to them
you know what do they get 14 minutes or
so with a patient they gave them
something that they thought would help
they were doing the the wrong thing for
the right reasons but they believed that
they were helping they didn't have they
weren't get catching Financial
incentives or okay got it that's right
those people we need to educate them we
need to train them on proper pain
management opioid prescribing
deprescribing and then you've got the
tiny little group at the top of this if
you will pyramid these are um docks
doing the wrong thing for the wrong
reasons these are bad docks these are
your pill Mills the these are people
breaking the law they need to go to jail
end of um the thing is is that that
little group at the top in the million
or so Physicians we have in this country
it represents such a small
representation but it got blown out by
the media and everybody else
particularly those docs doing the right
thing for the right reasons got caught
up in it and engendered huge amount of
fear huge amount of fear on the
physician side and then what happened is
the docs just started abandoning
patients they cut their patients
off um I had a young housewife two young
kids uh doc Cut Her Off from a little
bit of vicadin that she was taken
intermittently for um um some back pain
that had been well managed on this she
was doing all the right things cut her
off she turned to black tar heroin you
know um California great state of
California tried an experiment where
they monitor death certificates in our
state for and the docs prescribing
opioids for that and uh they went after
the docs thinking that if they targeted
the docs doing that it would lead to a
reduce a reduction in opioid deaths it
led to a doubling I know
counterintuitive because what happened
is the docs abandon the
patients and so we have to be aware of
the negative consequences of this now
the current I'm not trying to minimize
the opioid crisis because it's real but
we also now need to put some context the
opioid crisis is being
driven by the illicit
fenel it is more if you just look at the
CDC data it's very clear that the fenel
coming in Via Mexico China and others uh
is what driving most of the
deaths um Keith um getting back to Keith
led a beautiful
uh Lance at Stanford Commission on the
North American opioid crisis and put
together a very rational plan I just
finished serving as a senior adviser to
the medical board of California where we
revised our prescribing guidelines
here they were very Draconian before
hard
limits made people fearful both patients
and docs and we've shifted it back over
to put the control back in the hands of
the physician patient
relationship uh we're hoping it'll make
a
difference you can see I'm I'm uh I'm
going on a bit here there's there's just
huge complexity in this space uh I
understand you're going to do an episode
you know some some time on it in the
future and I hope the audience has more
opportunity to listen to this other
questions I can answer for you on that
now I really appreciate the thoroughness
of your answer um I think that you set a
picture in a context that I certainly
didn't understand or appreciate um and
it sounds like one certainly not the
only but one of the major issues is the
creation and the propagation of a black
market by doctors cutting off patients
presumably out of fear um those patients
then
seeking not any but um illicit or black
market routes to treating their pain
which you can understand why they would
do that I mean I'm not justifying anyone
doing anything illegal but somebody's in
pain
and they had something that worked and
now they don't and they're going to go
looking for things that are similar to
that thing and um you're telling us that
fentanyl in street drugs basically is
what's killing people presumably I doubt
it's fentanyl prescribed by physicians
or perhaps it is it's not no there used
to be a bit of confusion around that
because fentanyl is a prescribed
medication in a patch form and in a
troch the troch used for of Life cancer
pain but unfortunately some of the
coding used by the CDC in other words
got that confused with the elicit and so
it took a while to get a better handle
on it but I think you know we do now yes
most of it is being driven by the fenel
and we're just seeing this incredible
epidemic wave of it it can be made so
cheaply brought across the borders
reasonably
easily uh something we definitely need
to do to address we want to be careful
about not
conflating that crisis with the issue of
pain which is an epidemic in its own
right and for the segment of people who
are using opioids
responsibly and effectively for their
pain
um and that's where again that Nuance
comes in um are there patients who are
also on opioids that have been weaned
down you can wean them down gently
compassionately and they do
better um the answer is
yes uh my partner Beth is just finishing
up a study on that and you know showing
that with Compassionate Care a number of
these patients can be weaned down who
voluntarily want to come down and
sometimes they find their pain actually
improves and part of that Improvement
may be that opioids have degrees of side
effects and by elimination of those side
effects and the the um the other aspects
they're seeing Improvement could you
list off some of the more um commonly
used opioids um you know morphine and
it's uh commercial Del uh commercial
derivatives Ms conton which is a long-
lasting version of morphine oxycodone
which by itself is a short acting
medication but when you encapsulate it
in a long acting version it becomes oxy
conton which was the trade name that
Purdue uh put forward um um fentanyl we
mentioned comes in a patch form uh there
are mixed agents like uh Tramadol which
is a kind of a weak opioid but also has
some uh what's called serotonin and noro
Perrine reuptake inhibition uh we've got
diloted which is a version of uh trade
name for
hydromorphone so there's a slew there's
I don't know more than 20 different
opioids within that list of 200
medications that we
have methadone is another one um people
usually think of
methadone is uh a medication used to uh
treat addiction people go to methadone
clinics it's a longlasting
opioid in the right person and certain
circumstances it can be used effectively
for chronic
pain um by and large they all have the
same or similar mechanisms of actions
working on opioid
receptors this is getting back to your
original question to me about where
these things
work there are opioid receptors in the
periphery there are rich sources of
opioid receptors in the spinal cord and
the dorsal um the uh back part of the
spinal
cord and then there are many areas in
the brain that are rich in opioid
receptors it's you know it's all a
naturally occurring area and when we put
in an opioid by
mouth we're binding to those receptors
and activating those neural circuits in
many cases when I say activating they
have an inhibitory role I mean that's
one of the major
parts is there any role for
benzodiazapines in pain
relief rarely if to I many of my
colleagues would say you know Sean it's
just a hard no
um I Andrew I'd have to come up with an
edge condition of somebody who has a
generalized anxiety disorder un poorly
treated with anti-
anxiolytics with chronic pain and when
you find you treat their anxiety with
like a benzo it helps with their pain as
well the but these are Edge conditions
by and large no got it and what about
katum I had a um a odd experience with
katum and I've never taken it uh the
experience was the following I started
learning about it hearing about it uh
from listeners on the podcast realized
by doing a little bit of a web search
that it's available over the counter and
that certain people like to take it
often like every day at low doses or
even higher Doses and that there was
huge variation in terms of the amount of
katom in the various products and how
much people were taking some people
talking about katom as something was as
if it were innocuous and we can ask
whether or not indeed it is innocuous
and so I put out a a tweet I guess now
that it Twitter is called X I guess I
put out an X anyway doesn't matter and I
and I said that my um first pass view of
the literature on katum the scientific
literature is that you know it had a lot
of property similar to opioids although
different as well and that it seemed
kind of odd and maybe even problematic
that it was so widely available and I
got
bombarded with um I don't want to call
them katum enthusiasts because what I
soon discovered was that these people um
were angry with me for um placing even a
partial Shadow on katum but what was
interesting to me was that they were
saying that in their case and I'm
assuming they were telling the truth
that katum had helped them get off
prescription opioids and that they
heavily rely on katum in various do
levels of dosage um in ways that they
felt really help them and so two things
happen one I've been put in the
crosshairs of the pro Crum Community not
not to a a severe extent but perhaps the
more important thing is and I want to
thank that Community uh in part for you
know now it's inspired me to do a deep
dive search on katum I'm going to be
interviewing one of the Laboratories
that's done a lot of the research on
katum later in uh 2024 but also it it's
made me realize like there are these
compounds that are available over the
counter that many people feel feel so
passionately about because they really
feel like it's helped them I'm not
saying it has I'm not saying it hasn't
but then again I've never taken it what
is katum at or perhaps what receptors
does it tickle and what are your
thoughts about katum and people using
katum and maybe I'm pronouncing it wrong
I've also heard Crome I'm calling it
katum yeah uh katum is this natural
substance that does have as you said
opiod deric um properties as well as
others that is not fully understood it's
been available well naturally for many
many years brought in to the United
States and I've heard the same stories
and I just want you to be prepared that
anything I say about katum there's going
to be some angry people after this and
it is what it is
um I have heard the same stories that
you have heard about people taking katum
and saying it's helping them to stay off
of uh prescription opioids or elicit
opioids and and I get that I think in
some way it's binding opioid receptors
and reducing the uh natural craving for
these other substances and it makes
perfect sense a methadone does that
buprenorphine which I didn't mention
before but is a is an interesting opioid
that U binds to these receptors and it
reduces
craving
um where I have challenges is in uh just
because something is natural doesn't
mean that it is safe we are seeing an
increased number of Overdose deaths
associated with
katum um is it poly substance yeah in
some cases it is but I think there's a
lot we don't know so so poly substance
people taking katum but also alcohol uh
benzos getting back to the
benzos
um personal
uh I think we need to put a lot of
research into this agent and if it
merits it I think it should be a uh a
prescribed substance I think part of the
challenge that we have is that we don't
understand the quality the Purity the
dose that people are taking of this
thing uh you know similar type of story
with cannabis by the way uh
so I'm hoping that we're going to get
the research that we need to really
understand what it's doing and whether
it is safe
and effective I'm left with a lot of
unknowns right
now you mentioned cannabis is cannabis
effective and by extension is CBD
effective for managing pain yeah there's
another controversial one you'll get a
few comments about whatever I say you
know in general listeners of this
podcast yes they tell us where they're
upset they'll also tell us where they
agree um our goal here is never to um
satisfy everybody but just to you know
some of this lands in the in the realm
of Highly Educated opinion um some of it
is still as you pointed out speculation
because we don't really know what Crum
sources people are taking or cannabis
Etc but um I think you'll find and my
experience has been that um people
appreciate that we're having the
conversation and we do read all the
comments and those comments often as I
mentioned in my earlier anecdote about
that tweet um often direct us to explore
things further and we can always have a
you know second discussion about this
down the line so we invite all your
comments and criticism cannabis
well here's what we know in carefully
controlled laboratory situations
cannabis has been shown to reduce
neuropathic pain that's that nerve
related pain from people who have either
nerve injury uh diabetic neuropathy uh
postoptic neuralgia terrible burning
nerve pain condition it has been shown
to reduce
that in small
samples from larger scale epidemiology
studies and even larger like Clinic
based studies that I've done we find it
has not been particularly helpful on
average compared to people not on uh
cannabis there's a lot we don't know
about the causality of that and the
direction of it but all to say that
there are um many many questions that
remain
um I think the challenge that I
personally have is that we're running
huge population level experiments as we
speak right now by you know providing
unfettered use of
cannabis and the bad news is is that
we're probably going to see some real
untour consequences of it and we're
already are um the good news is I'm
hoping that at a state level we'll be
able to use that data to really
inform um what's going on with cannabis
I mean some of the challenges are what I
referred to with catom uh cannabis is
not cannabis is not cannabis you the THC
to CBD ratios the dose yes all of that
we don't know what you're getting it
remains a scheduled One Drug by the DEA
um I uh in some of my leadership roles
and others have called for scheduling of
it as a schedule to why why not to
purpose try to restrict use but by
making it a schedule to drug you've now
made it so much easier to
research uh I don't know if people
understand how many barriers there are
to scientists studying schedule one
drugs could you explain schedule one
versus schedule two thank you yeah so
schedule the scheduling of drugs is a
categorization that describes their
abuse
liability and so you have drugs like PCP
heroin um cannabis which are schedule
one which are defined as having high
addiction potential and no uh utility
which is just wild because when I think
about PCP Fen cycline I certainly don't
want people to run out and start taking
PCP but chemically and physiologically
PCP is ever so similar to
ketamine and you know rarely is this
discussed but ketamine is now uh widely
used as a therapeutic presumably
ketamine isn't schedule two um maybe
even schedule three yes and so some of
the the the stuff that's thrown into
schedule one makes no sense it's
historical it's all his it's decades and
decades ago of history and clearly
cannabis should not be a schedule one
hands down no
question uh by scheduling it though you
will have the societal benefit of being
able to make it more easy to study
and then you get the NIH and the FDA
into this and we can start really
getting answers to the questions which I
do I think it works at the end of the
day do I think there is some
variation of cannabis THC CBD ratios
that will provide some benefit oh
absolutely there's too many receptors in
our brain that are involved with
modulation of pain I just don't know
what those are um a friend of mine uh uh
Mark Wallace uh runs pain at UC San
Diego has come up with a really nice
recipe cocktail of ratios of THC to CBD
that he feels very strongly that he can
help people um using that as an active
agent yeah I know that in uh Colorado
there's a strain of cannabis where they
it's pure CBD no THC I think they call
it Charlotte's Web and parents of
children with intractable epilepsy will
actually move to the state of Colorado
in order to get it because it seems to
be effective for the treatment of
certain forms of pediatric epilepsy that
was shared with me with one of our
colleagues Nolan Williams when he was a
guest on the podcast so these
plant-based compounds have have their
place whether or not it's katum perhaps
right we're remaining open about that or
cannabis the T the THC or the CBD or
some combination I think it's really
interesting I think as long as we're
talking about plant compounds how do you
view the fields that are what I would
call somewhat adjacent to traditional
medicine so things like acupuncture
Chiropractic physical therapy and so
forth as a pain
physician uh within the field of pain
medicine or pain management I think
about six broad categories of therapies
that we provide for people with chronic
pain one of these uh is the
medications and there's a whole large
group of categories of medications of
200 or so uh available two nerve blocks
uh and procedures these range everything
from trigger point injections to nerve
blocks with local anesthetic and steroid
on up to minimally invasive procedures
like spinal cord
stimulators uh implantation of drug
delivery pumps three psychological and
behavioral therapies pain psychology
which has many forms now can be very
effective four physical and occupational
therapy approaches to chronic pain five
this is what we we typically call
complimentary alternative medicine
approaches it's a little bit of an
outdated term but I think of that as
acupuncture
neutraceuticals these are the
over-the-counter agents that have
actually shown to have benefit in pain
that you can get over the- counter and
last but not least six what I call
self-empowerment uh or increasing your
agency and here it's about education
it's about uh learning skills it's about
being here on the hubman you know Lab
podcast learning about pain um it's it's
that self-empowerment and what we find
is that those six categories all brought
together typically have the best benefit
for people living with chronic pain to a
lot of people listening to the US right
now think oh yeah acupuncture I mean
this is a you know thousands or tens of
thousands of years old practice that
clearly is grounded in a lot of clinical
data and clearly works and then other
people will go oh my goodness they're
talking about acupuncture like sticking
needles in the body are they just like
pain treats pain is that what it is
about but um as you and I both know
unless it's being performed um
incorrectly acupuncture is not painful
to receive does
acupuncture help treat certain forms of
pain is there any scientific basis yes
yes there is um do I understand what's
going on with acupuncture having
completed an AC an NIH funded
acupuncture study I just saw that uh
published no uh you know I'm I'm just
being straight um we still don't know
exactly how acupuncture is working uh we
do know that there's a nice study that
showed activation of peripheral
adenosine receptors that have a
peripheral analgesic effect we know that
acupuncture and as compared to Sham
acupuncture engages different brain
regions it's interesting that many of
the acue points overlap peripheral
nerves and so by needling those nerves
are we causing a central change we're
turning down the amplifier if you will
in the brain
maybe um where does this fit into my
clinical use my usual statement is that
if you can afford the wallet biopsy give
it a try although find a really good
acupuncturist I've oh yeah yeah I've had
acupuncture
done uh I wouldn't say many times but
several times and I will say this um
one of the acupuncturists I went to put
needles in my face and I ended up having
to go to Stamford Derm to get some of
the angomas that were the like blood
vessel growth that was the consequence
of those needle insertions and so I to
the point where I won't if I go to
acupunct I'm like don't put anything
don't put any needles in my face cuz
I'll take an angom on my leg or whatever
I don't care and I it's not vanity but I
didn't like the way that the needles
were introducing angomas to my face now
that was probably because this
acupuncturist wasn't doing things
correctly not saying all acupuncturist
do that but here's the problem how do
you know which acupuncturists are
reliable versus not and for that matter
how do you know which physici is
reliable versus not I mean I work at an
institution like Stanford where I can
ask a lot of people and I still my uh
senior administrators won't like this
but when I get a recommendation from a
doc at Stanford I always call somebody
at UCSF and cross check yeah and I don't
tell them that I'm cross-checking and
I'll do the reverse as well when I when
I was at UC San Diego I would check up
with Stanford so but most people don't
have access to that kind of community I
mean I can pick up the phone and contact
somebody in pretty much any medical
specialty and at multiple institutions
but for most people they're waiting into
the abyss of acupuncturist of Physicians
I mean how are people supposed to
navigate this you found a perfect way to
do it and many of us do the same thing
and for those who don't have access to
highquality experts you can use
variations of that so you're right with
acupuncture most of the ones I've been
associated with we use in the clinic or
outside are all have been high
quality the recommendation would be to
try to get uh a referral or
recommendation from somebody who refers
to that
acupuncturist docs want to have
relationships with people with other
clinicians that do a really good job we
don't want to be referring to somebody
who's bad because it reflects badly on
us so it's really really doing what in a
way what you were doing so try to
connect with your primary care doctor
others and get some recommendation um
for who is high
quality
um with regard to clinicians pain
Physicians for
instance that's tough there's 5 to
10,000 of us that are Subs specialty
trained out there if
your pain is really complicated a
complex pain proc you're probably better
off with a tertiary referral center that
can provide comprehensive Services where
possible so is there a is there a
centralized website where people can say
okay I live in the state of Iowa or I'm
um you know a lot of our listeners are
overseas or you know where people can
find out the like the uh the ratings
based on patient experience although
that can be complicated I confess sure
the one star out of five star ratings
are are a little bit more Salient there
have been studies on this people tend to
if you know you see a negative review
those tend to grab your attention even
if there fewer of them than the many
thousands of positive reviews but I mean
patients should be able to get the
information that they want about
previous patients experience right yeah
I got to tell you the uh the patient
ratings um it's a highly
manipulated situation um how so well you
can pay companies to help jack up your
ratings I see that's it's rather easy I
see it in the community infation of
ratings oh my yes inflation of ratings
and so then you inflate it and it
overcomes any of the negative ones um we
haven't taken an approach uh on this and
maybe that's naive of us um you know we
see 25,000 patient visits a year and
only a tiny percentage of them put some
rating and it's probably the extremes
undoubtedly but we don't manage it I
know that in many Community settings
that they do I didn't answer your
question is there a reliable source of
of quality I still think at the end it's
going to be uh relationships and word of
mouth and referral I do the same thing
you do I you know to see Hannah Watford
the allergist I asked my primary care
doc at Sanford who's the best who is the
person that knows the most about food
related issues well some really
entrepreneurial guy or gal or group of
guy or gals will put together a website
or an app or something that really uh
addresses this problem head on
I think very few things more useful than
a truly independent way of understanding
prior patient experience and finding the
best person for a particular problem and
I think AI can help with this but I
think Ai and you know human interface
anyway somebody out there should do it
um I'm curious about
Chiropractic for a lot of people again
not chiropractors let's not talk about
the people specifically but Chiropractic
a lot of people put acupuncture and
Chiropractic um adjacent to one another
but my understanding is that insurance
often will cover acupuncture but not
Chiropractic work um maybe I got that
backwards or maybe I'm just all out
wrong but you know with Chiropractic
work you're talking about often the
attempt to relieve um compression of
nerves certainly nerves are being
manipulated if any part of the body is
being manipulated I guess manipulate is
kind of a word that implies something
Sinister is happening is being um
adjusted um what are your thoughts about
chiropractors assuming the chiropractor
is well trained and responsible can it
help pain can it help back pain neck
pain whole body pain yeah first of all
uh acupuncturist and Chiropractic are to
entirely different professions just to
just to be clear for people and they
sometimes get lumped into a similar
category of pain treatments and that may
be where uh you know that comes from uh
just closing out on the acupunct Ure
again um just to summarize yes in some
patients in some circumstances I found
acupuncture to be useful and it's worth
a try CMS uh Center uh Medicare uh is
now paying for acupuncture for people
over the age of 65 uh Medicare for
Medicare patients that's something
recent and uh we were happy to see that
I believe that was for back pain that
should be fact checked um but
Chiropractic
mixed
data um well-controlled studies some of
some have shown that it can be helpful
for low back pain uh some have shown it
isn't it's it's
truly not clear uh the type of
Chiropractic that involves uh that
doesn't involve kind of you know the the
fast High Velocity manipulation as a
physician I have some concerns about
that particularly around the neck uh
I've taken care care of patients that
have had vertebral artery dissections
from um that rapid wrenching what is a a
vertebral Artery Dissection one of the
the the main arteries that goes um from
the body to the brain and the back
portion of it is called the vertebral
artery and uh when you do these high
velocity manipulations uh there is a
risk albeit small of having a dissection
or an emis thrown off and I've had so
it's like a stroke it's like it is a
yeah it's like a stroke um but there's a
lot of approaches that can be done that
uh and some patients have shown some
shown some benefit I think the key with
a number of these therapies and I don't
want to single out ACC acupuncture or
Chiropractic if you go to them ask
yourself am I getting durable
benefit
meaning everybody feels good after after
a massage right but couple few hours
later it's kind of worn off it's a nice
experience in the moment for most
people if you're finding that for
acupuncture Chiropractic or anything for
that matter you know ask yourself is it
really providing
you durable benefit that is worth the
effort um or is it just rapid it feels
good in the moment
we tend to use that in our clinical
practice as a threshold you know and we
like to see things that last for a
longer period of time and in many of
these
treatments whether it be acupuncture
Chiropractic we use those as an inroad
into more of a functional rehabilitative
approach uh meaning when you get chronic
pain you tend to uh withdraw you tend to
stop ex exercising you stop moving your
muscles atrophy you become
deconditioned because of the pain and so
we want to use these tools that we've
been talking about as a way to get
people engaged in activity to correct
the underlying biomechanical issues that
may be present and so they all need to
be appropriately staged and that's where
working with a good clinician can help
with that yes certainly in my case
anytime I've had back pain even when it
was very severe provided I wasn't harmed
and I was just hurt uh continuing to
move and not becoming sedentary was
absolutely the fastest route to recovery
and um and in particular doing certain
exercises that uh that were particular
to my my case um what if any is the role
for physical therapists in the treatment
of chronic pain absolutely crucial
absolutely crucial uh despite being a
physician not a physical therapist I
have great appreciation and respect for
what the physical rehabilitative
approaches do because at the end of the
day we're trying to get people back to
an improved quality of life and physical
functioning I mean that an is often what
people are most looking for control over
their pain control over their life yes
reduction in pain but more being able to
do more things and there tying in with
good physical therapist occupational
therapists people who can do uh goal
setting uh absolutely critical all of
the treatments that I
provide typically are meant to help
support an increase in physical
rehabilitative approaches and so when I
do nerve blocks or procedures or give a
medication and if we end up reducing
some pain we want to tie that in with
more
activity and what the physical
therapists are great particular i al
those trained in chronic pain is knowing
that difference between hurt and harm
they can work with people to know what
safe for them to do to rehabilitate they
can teach them uh more about body
mechanics and help improve endurance and
strength uh they can work around pacing
pacing is so critical for people with
chronic pain now this isn't just
exclusive to the physical therapists the
psychologists do pacing I do pacing in
what is
pacing here's the problem with chronic
pain one of the many problems it waxes
and wains and so what happens is you go
out and have a good day you go out like
Gang Busters and you go do everything
that you haven't been able to do for the
last week because you've been in
pain and then you pay the
price and when you pay the price you're
back in bed or you're on the couch and
you're not moving and what happens is
you go into this roller
coaster
of activity and no activity at all and
what happens is it entrains in our brain
it's a classic negative reinforcement
model this is classic
psychology and so then people become
fearful of more
movement and as a consequence they get
more and more um
disuse uh atrophy and then more
disability so the key what do you do
about
that the key is you set small goals baby
steps if you can walk comfortably for a
block right
now great walk that block tomorrow maybe
walk a block plus an extra 50 feet and
maybe the next day another 50 feet no
more no more if you're having a great
day don't go do five
blocks you're training for a marathon
you're training for the long wind now
what's going to happen along the way is
that you're going to have good days and
you're going to have bad days on the
good days don't go out and exceed it set
a threshold time it on your watch set a
Distance on the bad days recognize we
all have bad days everybody has bad
days and you know you may need some rest
during those bad days but then the next
day get up and restart you know where
you were
and that's the type of thing a physical
therapist good pain psychologist good
physician can help you with and tying
that in by the way with these other
therapies very interesting I've never
heard of pacing but it makes total sense
and I can see how people could really
hinder their own progress without that
basic understanding which thanks to you
we now have um and it's something that
hopefully all these therapeutic
modalities keep in mind I mean I I don't
know whether or not the acupuncturists
are talking to the physical therapists
are talking to the physician but I guess
this is the reason for referrals right
why somebody has a primary care dock
then it then it you know radiates down
to uh the rest is that why in a in an
ideal utopian world that's exactly it I
mean outside of uh Comprehensive Pain
centers that have all of the stuff
collocated you are dependent on a dock
to play
quarterback uh and bring all those
referral
together it's incredibly challenging for
a primary care doc to do that with the
limited amount of time they're given to
see a person um this is where we're
trying to use technology to to help
better with that integration and I I do
think there's hope for the future we'll
have better ways of managing that and
handling it what is your view on
non-prescription compounds so-called
supplements or neutral for the treatment
of pain fascinating
topic this country is rather unique in
having uh you know a wide slew of
over-the-counter agents that are
actually um prescription in Europe and
in other
countries and there are over-the-counter
agents that have been shown to be
effective for a number of pain
conditions so for neuropathic pain
acetel carnitine is one of them aceto
carnitine is thought to work on mod
andrial metabolism and improv
mitochondrial health and it's been used
I believe as a anti-aging and maybe even
a cognitive enhancement agent um you
need and it's been studied out of an
Australian study I think it was called
the Sydney trials uh actually and what
they found it's one of the few
over-the-counter
agents that actually had disease
modifying properties meaning they
studied this in diabetic
neuropathy the clinical endpoint was not
pain reduction the clinical endpoint was
nerve conduction velocity changes and
that's how we monitor nerve health is in
a normal nerve they move nerve pulses
move at a certain rate and when they're
injured from diabetes they they you know
it's much slower and you lose signal
this actually improved nerve Health you
can buy those at a vitamin shop uh order
them online uh alphal lipoic acid is
another one alphal lipoic acid uh at
least two mechanisms one is it's a free
radical
scavenger and second uh that's been more
recent is it is a ttype calcium channel
modulator and calcium channels are in
our nerves and it uh turns those down
and it can have some benefit for
neuropathic pain um people have
taken alphal lipoic acid for a general
sense of
well-being and it is generally well
tolerated it can cause a little bit of
stomach upset I will tell you I took
this one myself for a while and this is
you know again just an N of one what I
found though is you have ttype calcium
channels in your heart and I do hit uh
high intensity interval training and I
was Finding I couldn't get my heart rate
over 150 so I had I stopped it um that's
not a adverse event that's just an
annoyance but that's useful um vitamin C
so if you're going in for surgery and
it's a maybe a nerve related surgery
that you're going to have they found
vitamin C prophylactically can reduce
the likelihood of having certain nerve
pain conditions after surgery fish oil
the
Omega-3s have been found to be
beneficial uh around chronic pain uh
more recently the data here is on
smaller numbers
creatine which I imagine youve probably
talked about it at at some length but
creatine has shown in small pilot
studies some benefit in
fibromyalgia and some other uh types of
conditions so there are a number of
these substances that are backed up
beyond the uh you know the anic data
that we joke about the anecdotal there's
actually good randomized control trials
and this is uh something that people can
uh easily take advantage of um just be
mindful that just because it's natural
just because it's over the counter
doesn't equate with 100%
safety meaning get educated about the
side effects and the Adverse Events get
educated about the drug drug
interactions the agent agent
interactions and for
instance there are these
over-the-counter agents some of which um
you want to be careful of and not taking
when you're going into
surgery because they can be uh platelet
Inhibitors and they can cause you to
bleed more isn't vitamin C one such com
uh
substance that that causes uh excessive
bleeding or or some people report that
um high levels of Omega-3s can increase
the um can reduce the viscosity of the
blood meaning you bleed easier the the
Omega-3s of fish oils yes absolutely the
vitamin C I'm not familiar honestly with
that as a blood thinging agent Maybe I'm
uh misinformed there or or maybe I'm
just forgetting it but that's that's one
I don't usually think of as a a blunt
thinner someone will put in the show
note comments one way or the other I'll
get corrected I I but there's a number
of these over-the-counter agents that
are uh that are available the vast
majority are innocuous that I've
mentioned that I've mentioned they
innocuous meaning they they don't uh
cause harm at the at reasonable dosage
um uh but they can have positive effects
well perfectly St it yeah well thank you
for sharing that list I think um as you
mentioned many compounds that are only
available by prescription overseas are
are indeed available over the counter in
the US in this area of neutraceutical
like a supplements is um still an area
that's actively debated depending on
people's stance but it's refreshing to
hear somebody who's you know a uh um
formally trained physician and um and
scientist who um Embraces so many
different approaches in in the treatment
of pain along those lines um perhaps
you'd be willing to talk about the
psychological treatments that can be
effective for pain again absolutely
critical in the management of people
with you know wide range of pain
problems and recall what we talked about
is you know this is no susception these
are the signals coming up to the brain
once it hits the brain you know we're
dealing with everything that person has
lived through and also is currently
experiencing meaning their levels of
anxiety depression how they cope with
pain in the past how they cope with it
now uh early uh life experiences it's a
paper that just came out in jamama uh
literally in the last few days where
they did a metaanalysis of brain Imaging
studies on people with early adverse
life events and what they found is
abnormalities in emotional processing
emotional functioning and people who
have these um giving strong evidence
that what happens to you early in life
impacts us as adults and stays with us
it changes our wiring
now this is where in part pain
psychologists behavioral therapists can
come in they can help with some of the
uh maladaptive coping the the thought
processes involved with pain they can
help teach skills so for the vast
majority of pain psychology this is not
your typical psychoanalytic lying on a
couch you know talking about you know
whatever this is about teaching people
skills um incredibly
helpful uh does it eliminate pain um few
of the things that we do actually
eliminate pain what we're trying to do
is Chip Away you know a little bit with
this medication a little bit with this
Pro some this procedure bit with
psychology we're trying to hit all of
these Pathways in
aggregate um to make a real
difference the pain psychologist use
classically techniques like cognitive
behavioral therapy which involves often
recognizing these unhelpful thoughts and
patterns that we all get into around
pain and even life to inter interrupting
those thoughts to helping people again
with goal setting and pacing to teach
people relaxation techniques through
deep
breathing um things like biof
feedback um in Silicon Valley where I
practice the engineers love the biof
feedback I'm an engineer by formal
training so I get it but it's that Clos
Loop feedback because remember the the
brain is controlling the
periphery and controlling the sympy
sythetic nervous system and when we're
in pain our sympathetic nervous system
gets revved up when the sympathetic
nervous system gets reved up blood
vessels
constrict uh heart rate goes up our
muscles get
tense um and we need sometimes ways of
learning how to calm down that
sympathetic nervous system um cognitive
behavoral therapy mindfulness based
stress reduction acceptance and
commitment therapy are some of the tools
that they use my partner Beth has
developed a brief intervention called
empowered relief yes I'm biased um it
works we've studied this in an NIH uh
funded study and it's a way of getting
eight weeks of cogni behavioral therapy
in two hours wow not meant to replace
CBT but as an additional tool and you're
going to see as time goes by more and
more of these tools come out and the
beauty of them
is they're going to be much e easier to
disseminate broadly to the public than
for instance a pill you know I can't we
can't just go put into FedEx or the US
Post Office you know start sending out
pills to everybody but we can develop
treatments
online that uh can teach people skills
and really help is that the plan for
this um
abbreviated but equally effective
cognitive behavioral therapy yes now
you're getting into kind of my beths in
mind my life mission so you know I've
spent the last 12 years building a uh
digital platform a health platform that
we've integrated into clinics and
capture highquality data covering all
aspects of people's physical
psychological and social functioning and
the reason for that is to address a
critical need that we have on better
quality data about people the data and
the information that we have on people
with pain and many health conditions is
terrible
and so I created this platform to be
able to capture high quality data put it
to use use AI in the background for
prediction and
now Beth has created these brief
interventions which we're
integrating and the notion is to make
that widely available for free we're
giving it all away like I said this is a
life
mission we both have been blessed to be
at Stanford where we have everything
but you know you go just 30 miles 40
miles outside of the Bay Area and you're
in a healthc care desert and I don't say
that disparaging to any docs working out
there but it's different there's only a
handful of large academic centers and
large practices in the country but you
get outside those those catchment areas
people struggle with how to get good
quality care you asked that question
earlier how do you find good quality
care and so we're working to make that
that available to
everybody fantastic I was going to ask
you as a final question what is your if
you had one wish for the future of pain
medicine and the treatment of pain what
that would be um before you answer that
um I'll just add an answer that you
already gave which is it sounds like the
implementation of this um incredible set
of tools and database that you've um
collaborated with Dr Darnell Beth
Darnell to uh to develop as at least one
of them so now that that um that answer
was given by me then you can it frees up
uh the opportunity for you to give
another answer what is the if you had
one wish for the field of pain medicine
uh going forward what what would that
wish be yeah
so a few years ago um I co-led for the
country the development of the national
pain
strategy and this was uh sponsored by
the NIH and health and human services
and I co-led this with Dr Linda Porter
from the NIH we brought together 80 uh
National experts in pain research pain
clinical care pain policy and people
with lived experience with pain we put
together a strategic plan for the
country on how to enact a cultural
transformation and change the way we
assess uh care for people with pain how
we educate professionals how we
communicate with the
public my wish would be for full
implementation of the national pain
strategy it
unfortunately uh took backseat when it
was released the same time with the CDC
opioid guidelines and the opioid
guidelines sucked all the oxygen out of
the room but the the Strategic
plan it was well thought out it's the
one that we have for our country it's
non-controversial
nonpartisan it is motherhood and apple
pie um and it's if we just actually
Implement what we put forward it'll make
a huge difference in the lives of people
uh living with pain is there anything
that people listening to this podcast
can do to try and move the
implementation of that initiative up are
there Congress people to call I mean
this how so I learned in junior high
school and high school uh what little I
attended and by the way go to school
folks I had to catch up a lot but I do
remember them saying that you know this
was a democracy is a democracy and that
um those phone calls and letters can
often matter for what um gets you know
sent up the flag pole and what
ultimately gets approved and implemented
beautifully stated you're you're
absolutely right and in fact the nidus
for the national pain strategy
originally came about through a number
of concerned citizens with pain doing
that very thing and lobbying what became
a bipartisan you don't hear that much
anymore bipartisan effort um to put
forward a national Pain Care Act that
got put into the Affordable Care Act
that called for the development of an
Institute of medicine report on pain
that led to the National pain strategy
all
starting with concerned people making
those phone calls and writing those
letters so that means means calling your
congressman and congresswoman leaving
messages I hear this works I mean I know
people they're doing this for other
initiatives um and one call two calls
doesn't make much of a difference but
that if people are saying um you know
this is important to them that people in
power eventually start taking action the
the legislators they listen and and in
part um Again part of this life mission
both to develop this platform I've
created a nonprofit um called pain USA
and its main mission is to help Advance
the implementation of the national pain
strategy and baked within that is this
platform also to use highquality data to
better inform the care of patients of
people with pain and to deliver high
quality um treatments because we do know
also that people listen to data and we
need good quality data to influence uh
those messages but please yes make those
calls write those letters it does work
well Sean Dr Mackey thank you so much
for everything that you're doing you
took us on quite a tour um in terms of
depth and breadth of the thing that we
think of and unfortunately in some cases
experience as pain although we also
learned it's highly adaptive in some
cases can protect us does indeed protect
us thank you for taking us on that tour
of the biology the psychology the
various treatments the context in which
all of this exists we touched into some
somewhat controver IAL areas but I
really appreciate the thoroughness and
the nuance and the sensitivity with
which you touch into all of those issues
and um just on behalf of myself and
everybody listening I just really want
to thank you you've um contributed a
great deal today to the public education
of what pain is what it isn't and how to
treat it so thank you ever so much thank
you Dr huberman I appreciate the
opportunity to come on and spend some
time and uh you're giving a platform to
help educate and inform people out there
I got to tell you Nobody Does it Better
you you've been absolutely amazing and
um thank you again thank you it's a
labor of love and I appreciate the kind
words come back again thank you thank
you for joining me today for my
discussion all about pain and ways to
control pain with Dr Shawn Mackey I hope
you found the conversation to be as
interesting and as informative as I did
to learn more about and explore some of
the resources that Dr Mackey mentioned
during today's episode please refer to
the show note captions if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zeroc cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you can leave us up to a five-star
review please also check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast if you
have questions or comments for me or
guests or topics that you like me to
include on the hubman Lab podcast please
put those in the comments on YouTube I
do read all the comments during today's
episode and on many previous episodes of
The hubman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep for hormone
support and for Focus the ubberman Lab
podcast has partnered with momentous
supplements and we've done that for
several reasons first of all momentous
supplements are of the very highest
quality second momentus ships
internationally which we realize is
important because many of you reside
outside of the United States third
momentous supplements tend to focus on
single ingredient formulations which is
important if you want to develop the
most biologically and cost-effective
supplement regimen for you to learn more
about the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast please go to Liv
mous.com huberman again that's live
momentous spelled o
us.com huberman if you're not already
following me on social media I am
huberman lab on all social media
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
now called X threads LinkedIn and
Facebook and on all of those platforms I
discuss science and science related
tools some of which overlaps with the
content of the hubman Lab podcast but
much of which is distinct from the
content on the hubman Lab podcast again
that's hubman lab on all social media
platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter it is a zeroc cost newsletter
that includes summaries of podcast
episodes as well as protocols in the
form of brief one to three page PDFs for
things like how to improve sleep how to
regulate dopamine deliberate cold
exposure deliberate heat exposure
exercise protocols and much more to sign
up simply go to hubman lab.com go to the
menu tab scroll down to newsletter and
provide us with your email and I want to
point out that we do not share your
email with anybody and again the
newsletter is completely zero cost thank
you once again for joining me for
today's discussion all about pain and
ways to control pain with Dr Shawn
Mackey and last but certainly not least
thank you for your interest in
[Music]
science